Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW. Unsere kleine Welt, mein Name ist Tim Prittlav, hallo und es ist Freitag der sechsundzwanzigste,
Februar zwanzig einundzwanzig und Freitag heißt Corona Wiekli mit mir und mit Pavel. Hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Bin ganz dankbar für diese wöchentliche Routine, weil dann weiß ich zumindest welches Datum ist. Weil ich einfach mittlerweile, wenn ich so zurückschaue, so was,
zwei Monate sind wir jetzt schon in diesem Jahr und irgendwie ist die Routine, die ich irgendwie seit Anfang dieses Jahres eingenommen habe, so konstant immer dasselbe.
Jeder Tag gleicht dem anderen, jede Woche, gleicht der anderen, ist echt erstaunlich.
Es ist ein bisschen ja wenn man dann so zurückdenkt so an irgendwie Reisen und nette Kneipen und Barabende und so.
Irgendjemand hat ja immer Geburtstag. Ja, ja. Aber auf der anderen Seite ähm hilft mir das natürlich hier auch enorm.
Diesem Rhythmus, weil ich denke, es ist einfach in dieser Zeit auch sehr wichtig, dass man sich ein.
Soll ich sagen, irgend so ein Popes, irgend so ein irgendwas Sinnstiftendes greift, egal was es ist
Ja? Also egal ob man jetzt weit in die Gesellschaft herausstrahlen möchte oder ob man sich sozusagen nur des Problems des Aufräums widmet.
Worin ich ganz schlecht bin.
Muss ich sagen, alle Träume und Vorstellungen davon hier mein Studio oder sonst auch nur irgendeine Infrastruktur von mir aufzuräumen, ist kläglich gescheitert, sieht alles immer nur noch wilder aus
Und ich glaube erst wenn ich so den Ausblick habe, dass ich irgendwas nennenswert wieder verändern kann und ich dann auch weiß.
Woraufhin ich eigentlich meinen Zustand ändern möchte, auf welche neue Konstellation, dann kann ich erst einen Plan fassen,
Was das alles sein soll, wahrscheinlich auch nicht besonders klug, aber so ist es.
Also ja, also ich finde auch, dass ich muss vielleicht auch meine
Denkweise ändern, aber irgendwie erzeugt diese ganze Situation auch bei mir ständig Blockaden im Kopf äh und äh irgendwie
Ähm ja, ist alles irgendwie provisorisch äh so.
Es war wahrscheinlich alles alles nur im Kopf, aber so richtig ja es es will kein,
richtiger Elan aufkommen, so bei also ziemlich allem äh was ich tue. So stelle ich fest.
Irgendwie das Gefühl da ist, dass es jetzt noch nicht, dass es jetzt ja äh nicht so richtig Zukunft, sondern nur vorübergehende Zukunft.
Das ganze Jahr ist eine einzige Beta. So. Hatte man das Gefühl, so zwanzig einundzwanzig ist noch nicht so richtig released worden. Und da wird irgendwie noch dran gearbeitet und das hat noch so diverse Bucks und es kommt einfach zu spät raus.
Mhm. Ja.
Na gut, dann lass uns mal auf das Geschehen blicken, sind in alle unsere Befürchtungen wahr geworden.
Ja ähm es entwickelt sich wie erwartet äh das Ganze im Wesentlichen hm,
als erwartet, also die Wende zum schlechteren ist ein bisschen schneller, ich dachte wir bleiben ein bisschen länger flach
mit der Neuinfektionskurve, aber wir haben jetzt doch eine rasche Trendwende hingelegt,
sind jetzt wieder in der letzten Woche auf fast siebzigtausend Neuinfektionen hoch von irgendwie.
Dreiundfünfzigtausend davor. Also es ist halt ein Zuwachs um siebenundzwanzig Prozent jetzt deutschlandweit
äh was halt ähm so ein sieben Tage R Wert von eins Komma eins fünf.
Aktuell ausmacht und dass ja mit steigenden Zahlen in allen Bundesländern es gibt jetzt kein Bundesland mehr, wo die Zahlen,
fallen würden und ja in einigen Ländern haben wir so, also gut Bremen ist ein Sonderfall, da sind irgendwie neunzig Prozent dazugekommen, die standen aber auch besonders gut äh,
da, aber das katapultiert sie jetzt äh in der Risikoliste äh an den zweiten Platz hinter Thüringen gerade
vor Sachsen-Anhalt und Sachsen, die aber auch jeweils dreißig Prozent zugelegt haben, also ziemlich viele Bundesländer, die so dreißig Prozent Zunahme hat,
Baden-Württemberg sogar vierzig und irgendwie am besten schneidet noch Schleswig-Holstein mit drei Prozent mehr ab, aber,
alles ja wie erwartet und ein bisschen schlimmer als erwartet und.
Ja mittlerweile machen sich definitiv die neuen Mutanten bemerkbar. So, das.
Kann man glaube ich festhalten und ja die,
B eins eins sieben Variante ist halt auf dem Vormarsch. Wir haben jetzt keine genauen.
Aktualisierten Zahlen, so dass die letzten Veröffentlichungen so vom RKI,
sind vom siebzehnten Februar, also jetzt jetzt neun Tage alt und gar.
Waren's zweiundzwanzig Komma acht Prozent,
von B eins eins sieben und eins Komma drei Prozent äh von B eins drei fünf eins, also der Südafrikavariante und null Komma ein Prozent von der
P eins Motation aus Brasilien so.
Und wir hatten aber Wachstumsraten, die pro Woche,
ja bei mehr als hundert Prozent lagen, also es hat sich mehr als verdoppelt und das heißt jetzt zehn Tage später können wir wahrscheinlich davon,
ausgehen, dass wir irgendwo ähm knapp
unter oder knapp über fünfzig Prozent jetzt liegen werden bei den Varianten, äh bei den Neuen, also um die fünfzig Prozent rum haben wir jetzt erreicht
und das macht wahrscheinlich ja den den Großteil des R Anstiegs einfach aus. Nicht alles.
Aber ja so zwischen wie sagen,
mittlerweile null Komma zwei und null Komma drei mehr Ro äh durch die äh Mutanten.
Also ich hab ja noch 'ne Zahl aus Berlin, da gibt's die Untersuchung ja von dem Labor Berlin, das ist ja so das größte Testlabor äh Deutschlands glaube ich auch.
Sind mit dem B eins als sieben schon bei siebenunddreißig Prozent angekommen.
Und in unserer Nachbarschaft in Dänemark, wo das ja auch äh schon seit längerem ähm angekommen ist.
Schätzt man derzeit so den Anteil auf sechzig Prozent, oder? Das heißt, schätzt, Dänemark wird ja extrem viel sequenziert, hatten wir ja schon mal besprochen.
Und nicht nur.
Testet. Zehnmal so viel wie bei uns pro Einwohner.
Und die meinen halt
Risiko für Klinikaufenthalt. Dadurch ist halt jetzt wie auch um sechzig Prozent höher. Also nicht, dass die beiden Zahlen jetzt so eins zu eins korrelieren, aber das sozusagen der aktuelle
und das ist insofern ganz interessant, als dass jetzt Dänemark und Deutschland tatsächlich bei den Zahlen, bei den Infektionszahlen so ziemlich gleich auf sind,
Es hat sich so angenähert in den letzten Wochen und jetzt auch denselben Trend aufweist. Also
nachdem wir da einige Unterschiede äh immer wieder ausmachen konnten, sind die beiden Länder jetzt zufällig
wahrscheinlich eher zufällig auf dem selben Weg, von daher wird's ganz interessant sein, zu sehen, wer jetzt mit welchen Maßnahmen wie da ähm was besser realisieren kann.
Wobei man sagen muss, dass wahrscheinlich die realen Infektionen in Dänemark deutlich niedriger liegen, weil die halt zehnmal mehr testen. Also kann man wahrscheinlich sagen.
Positiven Quote ist erheblich niedriger.
Die positiven Quotes bei null Komma drei Prozent glaube ich in in Dänemark ja und.
Wo sind wir jetzt angekommen.
Wir sind immer noch bei sechs irgendwas.
Eins zwei.
Sechs Komma eins zwei, ja? Also da vielleicht auch ja zu den Tests Zahlen so äh von KW sechs auf KW sieben hat sich da eher wenig getan. Es sind zwei Prozent mehr Tests,
geworden und ja,
die positiven Quote ist aber nochmal um sechs Prozent zu äh äh um um vier Komma acht Prozent zurückgegangen auf sechs Komma.
Eins zwei Prozent, ja, also das heißt, wir haben ungefähr eine zwanzig Mal höhere Positivquote als,
Dänemark.
Das ist schon enorm, ne? Und vor allem bremst sich der Rückgang der positiven Quote ab.
Wir haben ja hier auch schon mal gesagt und festgestellt,
dass diese positiven Quote so oder so im im Großen und Ganzen das Gesamtgeschehen der Pandemie,
ganz interessant abbildet. Ich sag mal jetzt mal nicht komplett richtig abbildet, aber
Das ist ein rela grob gesehen kann man daran ganz ganz gut sehen wie es verläuft und das erlaubt vor allem auch so ein ganz äh unprofessionellen Vergleich, der der äh ersten Welle und der zweiten Welle,
Immer wieder, ne? Also einerseits kann man dieser positiven Quote so ein bisschen ansehen, dass die erste Welle natürlich hätte noch äh höher liegen müssen mit den gemessenen Infektionszahlen.
Stichwort äh Dunkelziffer, aber man sieht eben jetzt auch, nachdem wir jetzt so einen starken.
Rückgang hatten der Positivquote, die flacht sich halt jetzt auch in zunehmenden Maße ab
mit dem äh steigenden Ehrwert und den steigenden Infektionszahlen, das hatte dann jetzt auch davon auszugehen, dass die sich jetzt auch nicht mehr nennenswert verbessert und auch das
weiß dann halt alles kollektiv hin, dass wir jetzt, ja, auf dem Weg in die dritte Welle sind und wenn ich mir so die.
Die R-Entwicklung anschaue und wie diese Infektionszahlen jetzt auch so innerhalb von einer Woche so richtig schön einen gemacht haben, könnte ich mir sogar vorstellen, ich weiß nicht, wie du das siehst,
dass so in der nächsten Woche das schon richtig schießt.
Ja, ja, muss man, muss man immer sehen, es gab halt zeitgleich ja jetzt vor vierzehn Tagen auch nochmal einen krassen Wetterumschwung.
So der kann sich in die eine oder andere Richtung auch noch auswirken, weil sagen wir, dass das so kalt war.
Hatte ich das Gefühl dann doch auch, naja gut, da gab's dann halt die ganzen Schlitten,
Partys äh und so und Leute auf dem Eis äh aber ja,
äh alles kein Vergleich jetzt nach dem ich sage mal äh Frühlingsbeginn oder wie auch immer man das äh jetzt pseudofrühlingsbeginn.
Frühlingswelle.
Im ja Frühlingswille.
Erste Frühlingswelle.
Wobei äh ähm also Wetter hat halt einen Einfluss, aber meine These ist da, dass der Wettereinfluss mehr über das Verhalten der Leute geht,
als äh über jetzt ja physikalisch, chemische Auswirkungen auf den Virus äh,
die auch da sind äh so und die kommen halt zusammen und das macht natürlich dann einen extrem
komplexes Bild oder oder schwierig wenn man da jetzt Korrelation zwischen Witter und Infektion rechnen will, das gibt ein sehr uneinheitliches Bild.
Da werden wir sicherlich keine Erfolge feiern können bei der Betrachtung. Da muss man jetzt einfach mal schauen, aber.
Einfach nur von der Entwicklung der Kurven her, macht's einfach nichts weist darauf hin, dass jetzt in der nächsten Woche die Zahlen zurückgehen. So, sagen wir es mal so.
Genau, es müsste schon irgendwas total äh mal wieder Unklares passieren, falls die Zahlen zurückgehen. Äh im Moment ist ja überhaupt nicht davon auszugehen, äh auch,
sag mal der der wichtigste Indikator ist halt eben immer Nachrichtenlage der,
sich so auswirkt und die ist halt gerade auch gemischt und aus der Politik kommen halt auch sehr gemischte
Signale, da wird halt auch nicht eindeutig kommuniziert, äh, äh, gerade es gibt 'n Teil der Politik, die glaube ich von,
Richtigkeit oder Notwendigkeit von äh ja harten Maßnahmen überzeugt ist, aber ähm.
Derzeit läuft's ja auf ähm die drittschlechteste äh Option äh hinaus äh von den Vieren, die möglich sind, die ich mal so aufgemacht habe. Ähm so die beste Option wäre halt
harter Lokdown sofort, ja? Bis die Zahlen einstellig sind und dann langsam vorsichtig lockern,
Variante zwei, also zweitschlechteste wäre gar nichts zu tun,
einfach nur zu warten bis die Zahlen hoch sind und dann einen harten Lokdown zu machen,
Ähm die drittschlechteste Variante ist,
Überlockerung zu reden und dann irgendwie symbolische Lockerungen zu machen, von denen aber kaum Leute profitieren, die aber die Nachricht senden. Es ist jetzt gerade alles nicht mehr so schlimm.
Zu einem schnelleren Anstieg führen und äh dann wartet man halt auf den Logdown und äh ja
die schlimmste Variante zum Glück wählen wir nicht, nämlich ähm sagen äh gar nichts zu tun, äh die Sache erstmal laufen zu lassen, äh bis,
die Intensivstationen voll sind und dann die Bundeswehr rufen. So.
Immerhin. Immerhin nur die drittschlechteste äh zweitschlechteste von den ganzen Optionen genommen.
Interessant ist, äh sich das Infektionsgeschehen auch mal nach Altersgruppen anzuschauen. Denn da gibt's ja auch ein paar gute Nachrichten.
Ja, also da gucke ich halt eher immer auf die Zahlen von Ländern und weil ich in Berlin bin, nun mal auf Berlin, weil äh wenn man das jetzt über viele Bundesländer macht, dann.
Mittelt sich das doch dann teilweise alles sehr aus. Aber äh ja, bei den Altersgruppen kann man sagen, dass erfreulicherweise bei achtzig und neunzig Plus wir noch weiter
hatten. Also das sind jetzt die Zahlen bis KW sieben,
Äh einschließlich äh die wir, die wir haben, also bis zum,
einundzwanzigsten zwoten sagen die Woche,
und da konnte man dann aber auch schon bereits,
leichte Anstiege sehen in,
den Altersgruppen zwanzig bis vierzig würde ich sagen ja also da von da geht jetzt die,
Infektion aus und man kann.
Deswegen darf davon ausgehen, dass die wahrscheinlich gerade so in beruflichen Kontexten äh.
Überwiegend Ansteckung erfolgt ähm ja.
Weil es ein bisschen uneinheitlich, ne? Also es gibt auch Rückgänge bei den ähm zehn bis vierzehn, also Schulen sind ja noch zu. Das heißt, da kann sich theoretisch noch was verbessern.
Genau und das sind halt die Zahlen wie gesagt sowieso schon äh vor sechs Tagen und
dann natürlich hat die eigentliche Infektion, die zu der Institanz geführt hat, so vor sechzehn Tagen dann ungefähr stattgefunden. Also für die Zahlen hinken natürlich äh sehr stark jetzt auch hinterher.
Umso wichtiger ist halt dieser Rückgang bei den,
alten Semestern, also wenn man mal nur auf neunzig Plus schaut, da waren wir dann so um Weihnachten rum bei über tausend und sind jetzt irgendwie gerade mal auf dem ja bei hundertvierundvierzig angekommen. Wie gesagt, ne, für Berlin
Das ist schon sehr offensichtlich, dass wir jetzt hier die Auswirkungen der Impfungen sehen.
Mehr möglicherweise, ja das ähm kann gut sein, wobei hundertvierundvierzig natürlich,
immer noch ein krasser Wert ist oder auch die achtzig, die wir immer bei den über,
achtzigjährigen, also achtzig bis achtundneunzig haben.
Klar, aber der Rückgang ist halt stark. Also wir haben halt einen extremen Rückrückgang.
Ja, aber wenn du dir das anguckst, äh wie im Sommer wir äh da teilweise nur ein, zwei oder auch
irgendwie eine Institanz von null hatten, teilweise bei den über neunzigjährigen des äh ja also,
wir sind,
da immer noch überall bei Institzen über der ersten Welle äh muss man sagen und selbst,
selbst jetzt ähm ja korrigiert, um äh eine vielleicht einen Faktor von zwei bei der Dunkelziffer der bei den Tests, noch viel wird's wird's nicht sein. Kann man immer noch sagen, dass.
Unser Tal, das wir jetzt durchschritten haben immer noch ungefähr so groß war wie der Gipfel der ersten Welle.
Also hat sich nicht richtig viel verbessert.
Ja mal einen kurzen kurzen Blick ähm.
Ja ins Ausland, dem wir auch immer machen, da ist es so, dass fast,
überall die Zahlen jetzt steigen, wo man hinschaut, also Europa, auch USA ähm nur äh in Großbritannien scheinen die Zahlen weiter zu fallen.
Und äh sogar aber auch in Norwegen und Finnland sind die Institutionen jetzt.
Auf einem bedenklich hohen Niveau finde ich. Das ist jetzt auch nicht mehr, das kann man jetzt nicht mehr als Erokovit äh bezeichnen, was dort herrscht. Ja.
Und äh Tschechien ist halt äh wer voll dabei jetzt
in die vierte Welle äh zu gehen. Und es ist auch, ich habe heute gerade wieder so eine Anekdote aus der,
tschechischen Verwandtschaft äh gehört so äh aus der entfernten Familie.
Wo äh einer sich jetzt angesteckt hat ähm.
Weil die sind halt eine Runde Skifahren gegangen jetzt zu viert und einer von den Jungs ähm
warte halt Kovit, aber das hat ihn jetzt nicht davon abgehalten mit den anderen halt Skifahren zu gehen, ja? Und die anderen auch nicht davon abgehalten, mit ihm Skifahren zu gehen.
Super.
Ja, so. Also wenn sich jemand fragt, wie äh.
Wie die Leute da jetzt äh also wie so Tschechien auf so hohe Werte kommt ist, weil die Leute einfach mal oder viele Leute einfach mal das überhaupt nicht ernst nehm.
Weil überhaupt keinen Bock haben oder,
ja noch immer, obwohl also es Fernsehen ist halt voll äh natürlich mit Nachrichten und die Situation ist halt auch katastrophal. Es sterben halt ganz, ganz viele Leute, aber.
Es ist wirklich merkwürdig, ne? Es ist ich frage mich, ob das irgendwie so, also was.
Keine Ahnung, also die.
Das nicht irgendwie.
Ob die das jetzt als, ich weiß nicht.
Zu sterben, ist irgendwie.
Oder Schicksal abgetan haben, gerade also natürlich nicht alle. So aber halt hinreichend.
Großer Teil offenbar ja hat sich jetzt entschieden es zu ignorieren und,
Tschechien ist ja auch offiziell, jetzt haben sich dort bereits elf Prozent der Bevölkerung angesteckt
Das heißt, mit Dunkelziffer kann man davon ausgehen, waren's wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich irgendwo bei fünfzehn oder zwanzig Prozent. Äh die.
Sich entschieden hatten, lieber Kovit äh zu kriegen.
Elf Prozent, krass, ja. Nur noch äh über also absoluter Spitzenreiter, derzeit ist äh Montenegro.
Die sind noch ein bisschen über äh Tschechien. Generell ist es so in Osteuropa gerade ein bisschen schwierig. Also auch Polen.
Steigende Zahlen und also nicht nur im Osten, aber der Osten insgesamt steigt gerade etwas stärker an. Säuft's, ja, also ist einfach keine Ruhe reinzukriegen, ne.
Ja, aber auch. Ja, aber wenigstens gehen wir jetzt solidarisch mit Europa in die nächste Welle hinein.
Ja
Nur die nur die Engländer jetzt mal wieder irgendwie müssen aus der Reihe tanzen hier.
Wieder aus, ne? Ah ja.
Pixel. Ja, derzeit sind sie ja da ganz froh mit. Und da muss man halt auch sagen, dass dass an der Stelle die Erfahrung des englischen.
Ja schnell hell Service in in diesen Fragen durchschlägt und ähm ja das scheint aus verschiedenen Gründen sehr gut zu funktionieren bei uns, da kommen wir gleich äh auch drauf, wird's noch ein bisschen.
Dauern, aber es gibt auch da schon ganz gute ähm Entwicklungen.
Vielleicht gucken wir nochmal ganz kurz, was so an Maßnahmen denn jetzt eigentlich beschlossen worden ist.
Also es ist ein bisschen unübersichtlich äh seit dieser Woche.
Galt ja also in Berlin gab's so diese Ansage, ja Schulen öffnen für,
alle Eltern, die ihre Kinder auch wirklich in die Schule schicken und dann aber nur erste bis dritte Klasse und geteilte Klassen und Mundschutz und Hass nicht gesehen, also mit durchaus ähm.
Umfangreichen Gegenmaßnahmen, um dann Infektionsgeschehen zu verhindern,
Thüringen hat wohl auch schon Schulen, Kitas aufgemacht, in welchem Umfang kann ich grad nicht sagen, ich kann nur sagen, es
gibt schon von sechsundfünfzig Schulen und Kitas werden jetzt schon wieder neue Ausbrüche gemeldet, also das hat dann halt auch die entsprechenden Auswirkungen.
Und ich habe nicht so den Eindruck, dass das ja.
Dass das alles so professionell verhindert wird, was da theoretisch verhindert werden konnte. Und alle hängen sich jetzt irgendwie an diese Schnelltests.
Und das war ja auch ein ziemliches Hin und Her. Ähm Schnelltests sind halt jetzt.
In dieser nächsten Stufe angekommen, also es gibt jetzt die neue Generation von Schnelltest, die eben so sensitiv sind, dass sie eben auch mit einer Probenentnahme im Nasenraum und nicht Nasenrückraum ähm,
auskommen können, dass da bin ich gespannt, ja. Also,
Jetzt ist ein bisschen mehr so wie Nase bohren und nicht wie am Hirn rumkratzen, das mag für viele Leute gelegen kommen, weil ich kann mir schon sehr gut vorstellen, dass das mit den anderen Schnelltests die Leute so ein bisschen ihre Probleme hatten
Tatsächlich sind bisher drei Schnelltests zugelassen worden. Vom Bundesinstitut für Arzneimittel und Medizinprodukte.
Einer von Siemens Hellscare.
Einer von Technomed und Lisna Ki GmbH ähm.
Erste ist, also der eigentliche Hersteller ja Entschuldigung, das sind die Antragsteller, die sozusagen die die's hier vertreiben, die eigentlichen Hersteller.
Liegen in China, nehme ich mal an oder?
Klingt jetzt auf jeden Fall chinesisch, habe ich jetzt nicht äh äh komplett äh und einer hier.
Könnten die sein? Ist das USA oder was das.
Egal. Auf jeden Fall, was mich gewundert ist, dass es hat, dass Rosh und Apport, die ja,
äh bei den bisherigen Schnelltests ähm eigentlich so am sichtbarsten waren, zumindest aus meiner Perspektive jetzt noch nicht mit am Start sind, obwohl die auch solche Produkte haben. Also vielleicht.
Kommen die jetzt demnächst äh nach. Also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass die Zahl von zugelassenen Schnelltests dieser neuen Generation jetzt steigt und offensichtlich sind auch die Produktionen ordentlich hochgefahren.
Ja, also Heal Jen war USA. Glaube ich, husten, also.
Mhm. Ja. Das ist sozusagen äh an der Stelle.
Jetzt interessant, ist natürlich die Frage, wo kriegt man die jetzt her? Teilweise sollen die halt kostenlos ausgegeben werden, wer es nicht erwarten kann, kann die sich halt irgendwie auch bei so online versendern äh kaufen, wie viel Erfolg ihr da jetzt mithaben werdet, wenn ihr die jetzt ordert, kann ich euch nicht sagen.
Es gibt dann auch noch, das packen wir nochmal in die Shownotes. Ähm eine Informationsseite beim RKI.
Zu diesen Antigentests, wie sie ja eigentlich heißen.
Da gibt's dann äh hübsche PDFs mit äh Übersichten und so weiter, die so diese ganze.
Geschichte mit wie darf man das verstehen und wie ist denn das jetzt hier mit positiv und und und falsch positiv und so weiter, wenn man sich das nochmal näher anschauen möchte ist das glaube ich ganz gutes Material.
Gut, dann schauen wir doch mal, wie geht's denn jetzt hier mit der Impfung voran? Also dieses Impf-Dashboard DE, was da relativ.
Schmal gestartet ist, ähm kriegt am laufenden Meter neue Informationen und Informationsanordnungen.
Da wird offensichtlich aufs Feedback geachtet. Das finde ich ganz gut.
Und dem ist jetzt zu entnehmen, dass zwei Komma vier Prozent der Gesamtbevölkerung Deutschlands.
Die zweite Impfdosis bereits erhalten hat. Immerhin, ja. Das sind also so knapp zwei Millionen.
Knapp drei Komma acht Millionen haben mindestens eine Impfdosis erhalten und wenn ich am Anfang,
dieser Zahl nicht ganz so viel Aufmerksamkeit geschenkt habe, finde ich sie jetzt oder nicht im zunehmenden Maße interessanter, weil.
Jetzt auch Ergebnisse haben, kommen wir auch gleich nochmal drauf, die eben die Wirksamkeit der Impfstoffe nach der ersten Dosis doch deutlich optimistischer bewerten, als man das bisher vielleicht erwarten konnte.
Also es ist ähm einfach ganz gut. Vorläufiger Rekord war jetzt am vierundzwanzigsten Februar. Da haben sie irgendwie hundertzweiundsechzigtausend Dosen verimpft.
Und wenn ich das richtig sehe, lässt sich ein sanfter Aufwärtstrend bei der Anzahl von Impfungen äh wahrnehmen. Also bisher war das ja eigentlich relativ linear.
Beziehungsweise sogar abnehmend.
Leicht, genau, leicht abnehmend, aber so, sagen wir mal, insgesamt äh war das eher.
Ja, also abnehmende Zuwächse sucht.
Ja genau und ähm aber dann dann sagen wir mal im Großen und Ganzen drauf geschaut hat, war das halt dann eher so ein, so ein Strich, so ein so ein so eine gerade Linie, so mehr oder weniger, ein bisschen hoch, bisschen runter, aber da passiert nicht viel
und jetzt kommen halt die Lieferungen äh in Fahrt und man sieht, dass die Lieferung den Impfungen jetzt doch ähm deutlich vorauslaufen.
Was heißt das Reservoir an äh an Impfdosen,
steigt an und das müsste dann eben die Impfpraxis auch in die Lage versetzen. Jetzt die Zahl der Impfdosen,
zu erhöhen und ich hab zumindest hier aus Berlin auch gehört, dass Ende dieser Woche.
Also grad jetzt die letzten Tagen, dass doch enorm an Fahrt aufgenommen hat. Also das war wirklich auf einmal richtig viel mehr los ist. Was da jetzt der äh.
Das sei die Bremse gelöst hat, ist glaube ich nicht so ohne Weiteres zu beantworten. Wir wissen ja, das ist ja so ein komplexes Muster aus.
Terminvergabe, Terminwahrnehmung et cetera, ne? Dann der internen Planung, wann,
impfen wir für ihn und welche Gruppen sprechen wir an und dann weiß man nicht wie gut äh sprechen die an auf die Ansprache.
Sind die, wie groß ist die Bereitschaft in der jeweiligen angesprochenen Gruppe,
Ja und jetzt kommt da so ein bisschen Musik rein. Mal schauen, was sich da für ein äh Impfer,
Trance entwickelt, ja, vielleicht auch mal ganz interessant, mal zu schauen. Äh da möchte man dann halt mal wirklich äh eine große Steigerung haben.
Aber ist auf jeden Fall noch ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr weiter Weg äh zu gehen und derzeit lässt sich auch noch überhaupt nicht absehen, wann wir hier auf nennenswerte
Impfzahlen kommen können. Ähm, die Unterschiede zwischen den Bundesländern zeigt, dass Impf-Dashboard übrigens auch an und ich finde die.
Signifikant ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, aber Rheinland-Pfalz.
Hat es jetzt schon auf drei Komma drei Prozent äh.
Mit zweiter Impfung geschafft, ja, so als Spitzenreiter, die ich gefolgt von Berlin mit drei Prozent. Am Ende Hessen mit zwei Prozent.
Und Niedersachsen und Nordrhein-Westfalen auch. Also die drei sind sozusagen hinten an. Woran auch immer das liegen mag. Das äh das kann ich nicht sagen. Ne?
Bei der Erstimpfung sieht's ganz anders aus, dass zum Beispiel Hamburg ganz vorne und Brandenburg ganz hinten. Also das ist ein unklares Bild. Na ja.
Anyway. Ähm jetzt geht natürlich die Diskussion los. Mehr Impfstoff ist äh vorhanden.
Einerseits, aber dann diese Lockerungswünsche in der Gesellschaft sind auch vorhanden.
Dann kam so dieser Plan auf, hm, wenn wir die Schulen aufmachen und wenn das aber eigentlich ein totaler Fehler ist, das zu tun.
Alle haben Angst davor, dann.
Ändern wir doch einfach mal das Impfregime und dann kam halt relativ schnell so irgendwie der politische Konsens zusammen. Ja, dann packen wir halt einfach die Lehrerin.
Auch mit in die Gruppe zwei und damit sind die jetzt sozusagen in der Lage, auch Termine machen zu können,
ich habe jetzt keine klaren Informationen, auch darüber lässt sich dieses Impf-Tasport leider nicht aus. Wie sehr jetzt diese einzelnen Impfgruppen eigentlich schon bedient sind? Also mir fehlt hier so ein bisschen der Prograz Bar mit
OK wir sind jetzt hier bei im, wie heißt das nochmal, nicht Impfgruppe, sondern Impf.
Priorität irgendwie.
Prioritätsgruppe eins, was weiß ich ähm wie viel Prozent von dieser Gruppe ist denn jetzt schon weg? Und wie groß ist die überhaupt.
Und was ist denn jetzt mit Gruppe zwei? Und was ist denn, wenn da jetzt Lehrer und Lehrerinnen,
auch noch mit einfallen, was ändert das dann? Und seid ihr euch eigentlich schon so sicher, wie groß eigentlich die Gruppe der vorerkranten äh ist? Also das sind noch so Informationen, die mir so ein bisschen fehlen.
So dieses, wann geht's denn los mit den anderen Gruppen.
Ja ich finde ähm was da passiert ist gerade ist auch wieder ich meine Katastrophe wären zu großes Wort aber.
Ähm ja äh ein äh doch ziemlich unschönes Durcheinander. Und ein ausgelöst wurde das halt auch durch die.
Wie wir jetzt wissen ähm nicht erforderlich gewesene Empfehlung äh halt Astra Sinnika äh nicht für ältere Menschen äh zu
verwenden äh so äh hat er auch gesagt, okay, da lagen die Daten äh zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht vor. Jetzt kommen Daten rein, die sagen, okay, die bedenken äh haben sich eigentlich zerstreut,
so
von daher ist es ein bisschen unglücklich gelaufen äh muss man sagen und dadurch wurde dann jetzt plötzlich ähm irgendwie als dann zusammen,
Nachrichten deshalb auch Astra Sinnica nicht so gefragt ist und dann sagt ah gut dann.
Können wir ja jetzt irgendwie mit diesem Impfstoff vielleicht andere Gruppen bedienen, die eigentlich jetzt noch nicht dran wären. Und.
Hm in den drei Gruppen ist es so, dass.
In der Gruppe mit der höchsten Priorität so gut wie keine vorerkrankten,
da sind. Also die medizinische Indikation kommt erst in Gruppe zwei. Und da wurden jetzt die Lehrer wohl auch mit äh reingenommen zusammen,
auch ein paar Polizisten äh sage ich mal, wobei äh
eben nicht Polizisten, nicht grundsätzlich, sondern nur welche die auch dienstlich so verwendet werden, dass äh sie ein sehr hohes Ansteckungsrisiko haben,
die anderen, die kein hohes Ansteckungsrisiko haben, sind halt in Gruppe drei. So, jetzt die.
Nächste Merkwürdigkeit ist das halt trotzdem jetzt schon Polizisten geimpft wurden, ja, wie ich vernommen habe, obwohl eigentlich mit Gruppe zwei noch gar nicht begonnen.
Hätte werden dürfen, dasselbe Lehrer auch eigentlich äh äh müsste die Gruppe zwei, nicht mal frühestens.
Im Ende März, April.
Ende April sowas in der Gegend äh äh überhaupt dran sein oder berücksichtigt werden und,
was dann auch noch eine riesen Katastrophe ist, dass in manchen Bundesländern, wie zum Beispiel Berlin,
das System komplett darauf aufgebaut haben, dass äh ja sich.
Irgendwie der der Staat oder irgendeine Institution einfach meldet und dann sagt OK hier du bist jetzt dran und es keine Möglichkeit gibt sich irgendwie selber zu melden,
Ähm gab es halt in der letzten Woche und ja aktuell auch noch einen,
komplettes Chaos, also 'n eigentlich 'ne wirklich KFKS Situation wo Leute die wie bei der Impfhotline angerufen haben oder beim Senat angerufen haben jeweils,
auf die andere Stelle verwiesen worden sind, die Ärzte überhaupt nichts dazu sagen konnten, die Krankenkassen nichts dazu sagen konnten.
Offiziell ist es jetzt so, ähm, dass wenn man jetzt medizinische Indikation hat.
Unsicher gehen will, dass man auch irgendwie in die Pipeline kommt dann äh,
muss man sich oder soll man sich an seinen Hausarzt wenden, der sich dann wiederum mit der kassenärztlichen Vereinigung in Verbindung setzt und,
wird das Ganze dann irgendwie entweder abgesegnet oder auch nicht abgesegn,
oder es ist noch unklar und ja dann kommt man möglicherweise.
Äh in die Pipeline rein. Es soll auch irgendwelche geheimen E-Mail-Adressen geben, äh wenn man die kennt beim Senat äh und an die schreibt, dann wird man wohl auch in die Pipeline,
geleitet, aber ansonsten ist es so ähm praktisch von.
Fast allen Leuten, die sich dazu geäußert haben, die haben versuchen halt seit einer Woche schon mit Ämtern und Anfragen beim Senat und hier und da äh irgendwie,
rauszufinden, was sie denn tun müssen, wenn sie denn jetzt gefährdet sind. So, wie sie denn dann eine Impfung bekommen und.
Ja, vor dem Hintergrund sagen, dass erstens Astra Senika auch,
bedenkenlos an Ältere verimpft werden kann, wahrscheinlich sogar für einen schnelleren und besseren Schutz äh sagt, zumindest nach der ersten äh Dosis. Ähm,
als äh MRNA im Stoff, also da durchaus gewisse Vorteile noch hat. Ähm ja, vor dem Hintergrund,
ist es nicht so richtig nachvollziehbar, wie es sein kann, dass jetzt äh auch junge äh,
Lehrer und Polizisten geimpft werden. Hm und äh ja das,
vor Leuten, die halt einen erheblich höheres Erkrankungsrisiko und Sterberisiko haben, sodass äh ja, man kann jetzt sagen, gut, äh man.
Könnte jetzt äh auch in der Impfstrategie sozusagen eine epidemiologische Komponente drin haben, aber die haben wir ohnehin schon äh nämlich über die Ärzte und Krankenhäuser und Leute, die in Heimen untergebracht
sind ist die halt dann schon gegeben. So.
Und gesagt, was aber jetzt passiert ist, äh dass man halt ja bestimmte Gruppen,
aus politischen Gründen vorzieht und ähm dadurch ja einfach äh schon wie ich finde, sich ethisch äh nicht einwandfrei verhält,
ja ähm das finde ich geht so nicht.
Es ist schwierig, ne? Ich habe auch mal geguckt, also es gibt in Deutschland äh.
Ungefähr siebenhundertachtzigtausend Lehrerinnen und Lehrer, ob die jetzt alle in diese Gruppe zwangsläufig reinfallen, kann ich jetzt nicht sagen. Aber ist auf jeden Fall jetzt keine kleine Gruppe.
Ja? Und wenn ich das richtig sehe, kommen ja auch noch Kitaerzieher et cetera äh eigentlich auch noch mit dazu. Die ich jetzt gar nicht benennen kann, die die Gruppe. Also es ist schon mal.
Keine kleine Zahl, aber auch die Zahl der Leute mit Vorerkrankungen ist keine kleine Zahl. Und das fehlt mir in dieser ganzen Debatte auch so ein bisschen, dass dass die Größenordnungen dieser Gruppen überhaupt nicht so richtig äh angegangen werden.
Unser Nachtrag noch zu dieser Lösung in Berlin.
Gibt 'ne Pressemitteilung von der KV, die halt sagt OK es gibt jetzt 'ne Lösung für chronisch erkrankte zwischen fünfundsechzig und siebzig Jahren.
Die die KV das irgendwie übernimmt.
Grea.
Auf Basis von äh Abrechnung ohne Ausstellung von ärztlichen Artisten.
A. Okay.
Abrechnungsdaten im Sinne von was kannst du ja also chronisch kranker heißt ja auch regelmäßige Medikamentierung mit irgendetwas und dann gibt's ja auch die entsprechenden.
Ähm belege dafür äh et cetera, keine Ahnung. Es ist sicherlich davon auszugehen, dass auch da äh noch das ein oder andere,
durch Siebfeld.
Das muss man abwarten. Gut, sicherlich spricht für beide Ansätze irgendwas sowohl für diesen,
Schleswig-Holstein, hier, wir nehmen mal einen ordentlich stabiles Bohrungssystem. Meldet euch an, Leute, wir gucken dann einfach mal, dann haben wir euch schon mal alle in der Datenbank und wir wissen ja auch gleich, äh ob ihr auch geimpft werden wollt.
Ähm und je nachdem, solange es äh noch Leute gibt, die,
in seiner Form äh höher priorisiert sind, kriegt ihr halt erstmal keinen Termin. Das ist so der eine Ansatz,
Heißt aber auch, du musst dann mit dieser Datenflut und diesem Ansturm auch äh klarkommen. Ähm und Leute müssen damit's ein Online-System klarkommen und da haben wir ja schon gesehen, in manchen Bundesländern hat das ja eine ganze Menge Probleme mit sich gebrach.
Berlin macht's dann halt andersrum, eben diese Don Call As Recall You Methode, die natürlich in dem Moment gut funktioniert, wo man gute Daten hat.
Wo man eben auch so ein bisschen zweifeln, äh kann und wo es halt einfach schwierig wird, ne, was qualifiziert jetzt eigentlich als Vorerkrankung, aber diese Überprüfung müsstest du natürlich im Falle der Selbstanmeldung auch machen,
muss an jeder jedes Termin ersuchen, muss dann auch noch in irgendeiner Form ja gefiltert werden und dann muss man sowieso wieder auf Ärzte zurück. Also,
ich kann mir vorstellen, das ist, sagen wir mal, in der Abwägung
ja äh sprechen Dinge für die eine und für die andere Lösung. Und je nachdem, was man da jetzt sozusagen als äh den richtigen Ansatz gesehen hat, kann man für die eine oder für die andere Lösung sein.
Bin selber jetzt noch nicht hier an diesem Punkt, wo ich sagen würde, dass es jetzt grundsätzlich falsch. Am Ende wird sich natürlich entscheiden, wie effizient ist das
Berlin kann man jetzt zumindest schon mal nachweisen, dass sie jetzt bei der äh Zahl der Impfungen relativ weit vorne sind, aber das kann auch was mit Verfügbarkeit von Impfstoffen zu tun haben.
So, was, was, wie man's eigentlich hätte machen sollen, weil gut war ja jetzt nur ein Jahr Zeit, sich darauf vorzu,
insofern äh so.
Muss man vielleicht da jetzt auch ein bisschen nachsichtig sein aber ja das ist in in dieser ich sag mal wenn man Gesundheitsdatenwirtschaft,
sage ich mal, ist das ist ein Jahr gar nichts, als normalerweise reicht ein Jahr nicht mal für die Spezifikation aus äh so. Ähm aber.
Äh sagen.
Wie man es eigentlich, also wenn wenn ich jetzt in Charge gewesen wäre, was ich versucht hätte äh äh hinzubekommen oder empfohlen hätte, zu tun, wäre ein äh,
System äh zu bauen, wo.
Jeder Bundesbürger wird angeschrieben, er kriegt halt so einen Token, äh mit dem er sich einen Account aufmachen kann bei dem großen System und bei dem.
Ja, die vielleicht bekannten Daten über ihn
da schon drin sind, die kann er dann sich sich anschauen und sagen, ja ist okay, Alter stimmt und und so weiter und kann dann entsprechend selber auch noch Daten eingeben oder erheben.
Auch immer, aber ja, jeder hat einen Account, kann dort nachgucken. Ähm.
Und äh bekommt quasi einen Impfranking, dann bräuchte man auch gar nicht unbedingt jetzt so explizit jetzt irgendwie die Gruppen, weil die Gruppen sind ja auch verdammt groß und das kann halt ziemlich lange dauern.
Warum nicht einen kontinuierlichen Score erstmal ermitteln, der sich halt aus allen möglichen Faktoren.
Ähm ergibt und dann ergibt sich halt für dich irgendwie eine Reihenfolge, wann du.
Dran bist, die du dann halt auch einsehen kannst und wenn sich irgendwas an deiner Situation ändert oder
an der Versorgung mit Impfstoffen oder so, dann äh wird das halt entsprechend aktualisiert. Und wenn das jetzt absehbar ist, dass so irgendwann in den nächsten Wochen dran bist, dann äh,
entsprechend die Terminvergabe organisiert. So würde ich mir.
Immunsystem vorstellen, Best of Boss, Worlds, äh, quasi ähm.
Und das kannst du dann immer noch auch problemlos mit.
Einladung verschicken an Leute, die sich dort jetzt nicht angemeldet haben, würde es dann aber schon mal auch dieses ganze prozide reduzieren, wenn die Leute klicken können, okay, danke, ich brauche jetzt keine.
Schriftliche Einladung per Brief, ich druck mir das halt selber aus, also solche kleinen Sachen so um auch.
Da kommt aber gleich der Chaos-Computerclub und sagt, also eine Datenbank hier mit den äh mit der gesamten Bevölkerung, mit allen Gesundheitsdaten beim beim Event äh Terminbetreiber.
Nicht beim Event Terminbetreiber. Ich hätte mir hätte da schon erwartet ich mein.
Finanzämter machen auch Datenverarbeitung, ja gut, da kann man jetzt gibt's jetzt auch keinen nicht wirklichen guten Self Service und so und ja, ich weiß ähm.
Es gibt da sicherlich.
Probleme, aber auf der anderen Seite äh ja ähm ich meine, so wie es jetzt läuft.
Also optimal ist es nicht.
Optimal ist es nicht, aber es ist ja im Wesentlichen der Kunstränd, ist ja bisher.
Sagen wir mal so, ich denke, dass die der Grund, warum es jeweils gerade mal nicht so schnell läuft, wie es vielleicht theoretisch gehen könnte. Der eigentliche Flaschenhals, der ist nicht immer derselbe.
Der war jetzt vor allem Verfügbarkeit von Impfstoffen.
Und in dem Moment, wo die verfügbarer werden, wird natürlich das Terminding wieder wichtiger. Ähm das kann sich alles,
jederzeit äh ändern. Gut, man sieht, wie es in anderen Ländern auch funktionieren kann, die da weniger Berührungsprobleme haben. Israel ist das irgendwie alles digital zentralisiert, das haben die irgendwie, glaube ich, in den letzten zehn Jahren auch erst so eingeführt.
Profitieren jetzt an der Stelle äh davon, dass sie da schon uns ein paar Schritte äh voraus sind,
Du hast sicherlich Recht, man muss letzten Endes da sehr pragmatisch vorgehen meiner Meinung nach, ja? Sich natürlich gut Gedanken darüber machen, aber vor allem eben zielorientiert arbeiten,
ähm.
Ich bin jetzt ein bisschen vorsichtig da drin hier ein konkretes System vorzuschlagen ohne die ganzen Rahmenparameter und äh das bedenken Trägertum, das.
Zu kippen.
Die Rahmenparameter äh äh sind so.
Dass es gesetzlich nicht möglich ist, was ich gerade vorgeschlagen habe, das kann man einfach mal sagen, technisch äh äh machbar, vermutlich auch,
machbar am Ende des Tages mit.
Für meinen Geschmack äh hinreichendem äh Datenschutz aber ja,
das ist ich sag mal zwei das sind sogar sagen zwei Größenordnungen von undenkbar und ich glaube wer.
Software jetzt für Krankenkassen entwickelt oder in dem Bereich jetzt Kassenärztliche Vereinigung,
Ärzte, Kommunikation, wer da mal unterwegs war, also in der Gesundheitsdatenverarbeitung, glaube ich, wird es problemlos bestätigen, dass das.
So etwas, was ich gerade vorgeschlagen habe, vermutlich ein Generationenprojekt wäre so zwanzig oder dreißig Jahre.
Müsste man da veranschlagen, um die ganzen gesetzlichen Grundlagen zu schaffen und das auszuhandeln, wie das denn dann am Ende ja äh unseren hohen Datenschutzrechtlichen Anforderungen genügt.
Gut. Ähm in dem Zusammenhang fällt mir noch eine andere Debatte ein.
Die ähm ja aus verschiedenen.
Richtung entgegenwehte, ja, der Sommer naht und damit natürlich auch so ein bisschen die Festivalzeit. Da wird jetzt schon fleißig geplant und alle blicken natürlich bang auf die Entwicklung der Situation.
Weil wenn du was Großes planst, dann musst du halt jetzt irgendwie dich drum kümmern. Ja, also.
Events macht man nicht mal eben so in zwei, drei Wochen, sondern das hat einfach in der Regel ein halbes Jahr Vorlaufzeit, je nachdem wie groß das ist,
Ähm dann gab's eine Meldung von Eventteam, die so ein bisschen Wind gemacht hat, denn ähm
kam dann so die Aussage, na ja, also wir haben hier unsere technischen Systeme schon mal so darauf vorbereitet
dass wir äh etwaige Impfausweise auch aus äh lesen können und berücksichtigen können und überhaupt würden wir ja davon ausgehen, dass irgendwie viele Veranstaltungen vielleicht äh sich dazu entscheiden würden.
Einfach nur geimpfte aufzunehmen. Ja.
Wobei, wo dann natürlich auch gleich manche gescherzt haben, dass die einzigen Großveranstaltungen diesem Jahr wahrscheinlich nur noch irgendwie die Roland Kaiser Tour und irgendwie die Flippers oder sowas
äh äh sind, ja, die sich äh sagen wir mal die älteren Semester äh widmen so, aber auf jeden Fall kein billig Eiskonzert.
Sicherlich auch ein berechtigte berechtigtes Bedenken und natürlich auch extrem schwierig, ne? Ich meine aus der Perspektive eines Veranstalters ähm.
Sind das natürlich schon Überlegungen, weil du möchtest natürlich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt jetzt, dass deine Veranstaltung dann so der nächste große Hotspot ist, beziehungsweise sind damit natürlich auch finanzielle und rechtliche Risiken verbunden.
Ähm vor allem wirft es auch rechtliche Fragen auf. Es gibt ja so ein Grundrecht auf Gleichbehandlung,
unserem Staatswesen, das betrifft aber eigentlich auch nur das Verhältnis von Bürger und Staat,
ja? Sowas äh gilt dann erstmal für private Unternehmen nicht in derselben Form
da herrscht dann natürlich erstmal der Grundsatz der Vertragsfreiheit, dass du halt selber entscheiden kannst, mit wem du irgendwie was wie machst und äh und so weiter. Nichtsdestotrotz gibt's aber ein.
Gleich Gleichbehandlungsgesetz in Deutschland, dass halt Diskriminierung verbietet. Und jetzt natürlich die Frage, was,
Was ist Diskriminierung,
Ja, klar kann man jetzt sagen, oh, hier ungeimpft werden jetzt diskriminiert, nur der Begriff der Diskriminierung erfasst das nicht. Das ist sozusagen kein Kriterium, an dem man Diskriminierung,
in der Definition dieses Wortes festmachen kann. Diskriminierung ist, wenn du nach Geschlecht diskriminierst, nach sexueller Orientierung, diskriminierst nach Hautfarbe, diskriminierst et cetera, die Liste ist nicht kurz.
Also ohne ja und uns ohne sachlichen Grund.
Genau und du darfst halt sozusagen schon diskriminieren, wenn du eben auch einen sachlichen Grund hast.
Ja, also wenn's eine klare Erläuterung gibt, so, ja, das hat sozusagen, weil Frauen dürfen nicht auf diese Veranstaltung, weil hier sachlicher Grund, der nachvollziehbar ist oder auch andersherum, ne? Und ähm.
Also bin dann eine Ladies Night machst suchte ist das vielleicht auch ein nach saftiger Grund. Egal ich will's nicht albern.
Ja oder Schwangere nicht auf dein Karussell ist.
Ja, genau, also man kann sich das alles vorstellen und.
So wie ich das rausgelesen habe, ist ja die Rechtslage auch relativ klar, dass also jetzt so ein Impfstatus hier an dieser Stelle nicht als Diskriminierung gilt, das heißt, wenn sich ein Veranstalter
dazu entschließt, zu sagen, so ja, nee, wir machen jetzt hier einfach Impf-Only, weil ich habe keinen Bock auf den Scheiß. So, dann dann ist das halt einfach so, ne.
Ja
Ja, aber ganz äh so aus meiner Sicht gut, auch wenn ich zwar äh jetzt kein Jurist bin, aber.
So wie ja von von allem hab ich auch 'ne ganz gute juristische,
Halbbildung ähm und ich würde mal spontan sagen ähm Probleme könnten aber auftreten äh bei der Frage.
Ein Veranstalter oder Unternehmen auch berechtigt ist äh den Impfstatus äh zu erheben,
weil das nämlich Gesundheitsdaten sind und die gehören wiederum zu den äh besonders zu schützenden äh Daten, wo dann äh ja besondere,
Anforderungen äh für das Erheben und Speichern und Verarbeiten dieser dieser Daten.
Speichern musst du es ja nicht unbedingt. Es reicht ja, dass du sozusagen am Eingang sagst, hier zack, da ist mein Dokument, das wird gecheckt. Fertig. Diese Information muss,
speichert werden und wenn,
dürfte ja heute kein Mensch mehr fliegen. Ich meine, diese Voraussetzung, dass du einen Corona Test äh hast, der so und so viel Tage maximal alter sein darf, äh um irgendwo einzureisen, beziehungsweise überhaupt nur das Flugzeug zu betreten. Ist,
Prinzip genau dasselbe.
Ja, also von daher so eine, so eine Kontrolle könnte funktionieren, setzt dann ja, hm.
Aber natürlich sind wir bei der, bei der Diskussion sagen Impfpass und äh wie das Ganze rechtlich auch geregelt äh wird und.
Lass mal den Impfpass nochmal ein bisschen äh außen vor. Ich wollte äh lass mich nochmal kurz ähm also ich wollte einfach darauf hinaus diese Meldung
Von Eventteam, die einfach nur gesagt hat, also wir werden soweit, ja? Äh die hat dann sozusagen Reaktionen äh ausgelöst und jetzt habe ich mal kurz diese rechtliche Situation beleuchtet, soweit ich das jetzt wahrgenommen habe oder auch nur eine rechtliche Haltbildung zu haben,
die Reaktionen da drauf waren dann ganz interessant, ne? Weil dann natürlich gleich wieder welche angefangen haben zu schreien. So oh ja hier Diskriminierung und so weiter.
Was äh erlaube Eventim äh ne? Ich meine Eventim ist am Ende nicht der Veranstalter, sondern andere, die machen das ja sozusagen nur zugänglich. Und dann gab's dann äh auch gleich so Wortmeldungen, was ich hier von Nena.
Auch irgendwie siehst du alternden Popstars und auch irgendwie alle echten Probleme, habe ich so den Eindruck,
war schon bei Nina Hahn nicht zu ertragen. Aber Nina Hagen dann auch gleich so, nein, sowas wird's bei mir nicht geben und ihr dürft natürlich alle kommen.
Dachte so, okay, wie
wie, wie sehr liebst du eigentlich deine Fans? Wie wenn du dann sozusagen auch bereit wärst jetzt hier ohne Second Sort irgendwie einfach immer alle äh bekommen zu haben, egal wie deine Impfstatus oder der Teststatus ist.
Worauf's wahrscheinlich hinauslaufen wird, ist eine Kombi aus Impfung und Tests.
In Duna halbwegs sichere Veranstaltungen haben möchtet, im Handel Vision dann auch als Veranstalter den Leuten dort ein.
Safe Space, weil man will ich einfach nicht sagen, ja, aber du möchtest es sozusagen so sicher gestalten, wie es geht. Und aus mehreren Gründen,
so
So, okay. Aber vielleicht kann ich dann doch nochmal äh nochmal was Rechtliches äh äh hinterher äh äh schicken.
Und zwar.
Erfordert ja, damit sagen das funktioniert auch eine entsprechende Regelung in der Korona
Schutzverordnung, das heißt, es müsste dann eine Ausnahme geben oder oder die Regel, dass halt bestimmte Veranstaltungen einfach nicht stattfinden können, so,
müsste halt ausgesetzt werden für dann ja Impfstatusberücksichtigung. So und,
da gilt dann aber wiederum der Gleichbehandlungsgrundsatz und da ist es dann tatsächlich die Frage.
Zum Beispiel jemand der durchgängig 'ne Maske trägt, ähm.
Äh dort das Risiko dann äh größer oder geringer ist, äh was von dem ausgeht oder dem er sich aussetzt als äh jemand, der geimpft ist, ja
also die Zahlen sind.
Mal zumindest ja vergleichbar oder oder dis diskutierbar so und in insofern ja ähm,
sehe ich, dass äh am Ende doch als politische oder rechtliche Frage, also wo der Staat äh explizit des entweder zulassen oder nicht zulassen äh äh kann oder wird.
Ja. Plötzlich nochmal ein bisschen klarer machen, was so ein bisschen mein Modell ist, ne. Ich denke jetzt äh im Wesentlichen mal so an an Open Air Festivals.
Das ist so ein bisschen die Konstellation, die ich jetzt zumindest im Hinterkopf hatte. Man kann sich natürlich jetzt tausende andere Veranstaltungen, Kinobesuche, Theater, Konzerte, äh Indoor und so weiter, alles auch vorstellen, wo man vielleicht sagen kann, das ist generell,
noch problematisch, ja? Derzeit haben wir so eine äh so eine Art Lokdown,
den haben wir dann vielleicht auch im Mai nochmal und so, aber was ist dann im Sommer? Ja, was ist, wenn wir sozusagen zwanzig, dreißig, vierzig, fünfzig Prozent Deutschlands dann,
so schön heißt, ein Impfangebot gemacht haben.
Aber wir uns sozusagen in so einer Situation befinden, wo auf der einen Seite viele Leute sagen, ja was denn, ich bin doch geimpft, dann kann ich jetzt hier auch feiern.
Ja und auf der anderen Seite halt die, die gerne feiern würden, aber irgendwie noch nicht geimpft sind und irgendwie den kein Impftermin kriegen, weil sie halt einfach zu jung sind, ne.
Und du bist jetzt Veranstalter und möchtest aber sagen,
ja hier schwierig generell mit Veranstaltung Veranstaltung sehen wir auch aber es ist Sommer, es ist draußen,
Ja, du hast also schon mal so die diversen Bonuspunkte, die du so bei einer Indoor-Veranstaltung nicht so ohne Weiteres bekommst,
und wir checken aber einfach auch, ob Leute geimpft sind und die, die nicht geimpft sind, die machen halt einen Test.
Sowie beim Flugzeug, ne? Damit du dann überhaupt die Zulassung bekommst für so eine Veranstaltung. Darum geht's ja.
Damit überhaupt irgendwas möglich ist, weil so irgend so ein irgend so ein Kompromiss wird dann halt auch gefunden werden müssen. Das ist.
Die Diskussion werden wir haben, egal ob ob ob wir sie jetzt gut heißen oder nicht, die wird kommen und zwar relativ bald.
Wird kommen, die wird immer lauter werden natürlich, je mehr Leute geimpft sind, keine Frage, ich würde es,
Aber also ich empfinde es als ungerecht und halte es auch für begründbar unethisch,
ähm wenn ähm,
ja äh sagen es Privilegien, also weitergehende zusätzliche Privilegien gibt für Geimpfte,
Äh die sagen explizit staatlich garantiert sind oder wie auch immer man das nennen mag
solange es nicht die Möglichkeit für jeden gibt sich impfen zu lassen. Also bevor es nicht ein Impfangebot für jeden gibt, äh so ähm finde ich das schlichtweg
ungerecht.
Ja, damit Kiss aber dann die komplette Veranstaltungsbranche in diesem Sommer. Weil das überleben die nicht.
Wie gesagt, nee, die die also die Lösung von der von der du sprachst äh jetzt, dass man, dass man halt sagt, okay,
halt keine Ahnung, Impfung oder Maske oder ähm ja ähm oder eben ja.
Impfung oder Test.
Ja genau. Also das kann ich mir noch vorstellen, aber zu sagen, so sagen die Impfung jetzt.
Mehr zur Voraussetzung zu machen als dass jetzt irgendwie sachlich unbedingt nötig oder erforderlich ist, das schafft halt äh ziemlichen gesellschaftlichen Unfrieden.
Ja gut, ist ja nicht so, dass wir die nicht sowieso schon hätten und äh,
andererseits ähm was ändert das jetzt sozusagen an deiner Situation? Ich meine, wenn du halt nicht geimpft bist und willst ja auch an sowas nicht teilnehmen. So
und es ist ja auch irgendwie unklug daran teilzunehmen und dann ist es ja auch ein Schutz deiner selbst. Also die wird die Frage, inwiefern man das jetzt als Privileg auslegt, ja oder eben nur die Wegnahme von Einschränkungen.
Also es ist sozusagen die Wegnahme von Einschränkung automatischem Privileg.
Ja ja ist es.
Dort auch äh äh ist, das ist halt dann äh ja.
Ich mein klar kann man da dann 'ne sachliche Kette irgendwie auch machen aber man läuft dann auch noch.
In das Problem, dass halt so wie die Gruppen derzeit gebildet wurden und zusammengesetzt sind, ähm wirft das auch erhebliche.
Gleichbehandlungsprobleme gerade auf, ja, äh, innerhalb der äh Gruppen oder Gruppen untereinander, wo.
Eben teilweise ja äh das sachlich überhaupt nicht nachzuvollziehen ist. Warum ähm eben, wie wir vorhin hatten jetzt äh dann äh.
Ja Lehrer oder Polizisten anderen Gruppen vorgezogen werden.
Und je mehr sagen.
Ich dann damit verbinde, umso problematischer äh ist das natürlich für die für die einzelnen. Aber gut, ich denke bis September sind wir durch.
Ja, da ist aber auf jeden Fall die Open Air Saison auch schon durch.
Meine Hoffnung besteht halt noch, dass wir vielleicht irgendwie dann nach der dritten Welle so auf die Idee kommen.
Dass man mal vielleicht die Institzen ganz nach unten bringt, europaweit und dann kann man halt auch aufmachen so.
Das wäre halt.
Meine bevorzugte Variante des ja, dass das dann sagen, deswegen keine große Rolle spielt, ob jemand geimpft ist oder nicht, weil.
Es halt so gut wie keine Infizierten gibt, die oben rennen. Das fände ich halt einfach am besten. So.
So oder so soll es jetzt einen Impfpass geben. Äh zumindest wird das auf europäischer Ebene diskutiert und ähm.
Das ist insofern interessant, als dass dieser digitale Impfpass ohnehin, glaube ich, geplant ist in Deutschland, ab zwanzig zweiundzwanzig, also nicht, dass ich davon ausgehen würde, dass das pünktlich kommt, so normalerweise, aber dass es
quasi der Plan. Ähm aber auch für diese Corona-Impfung. Also es geht jetzt nicht um Impfpass im Sinne von da sind alle deine Impfungen drin, sondern sie reden halt.
Sobald ich die Diskussion verstanden habe, um eine elektronische Lösung oder digitale Lösung für einen Nachweis einer Corona.
Impfung und das wird EU-Weit. Also auch für für EU-Weit diskutiert.
Ist halt die Frage, ne? Also wenn's so ein so ein so ein Ding gibt, zum Nachweis, dann muss er auch irgendwann mal nachgewiesen werden können.
Also offensichtlich wird schon darüber nachgedacht. Ähm Momente zu haben, wo das getestet wird.
Bin mir auch ein bisschen unsicher darüber, wie wie Feldspar das dann sein wird, aber wenn der heutige Impfpass die Grundlage ist ich meine, hast du dir dein Impffass mal schon mal angeschaut? Das ist halt so.
Bisschen gekritzelt und ein paar Aufkleber.
Ja, ich habe da noch irgendwas von der Bundeswehr.
Ja und wenn der, wenn das sozusagen das das Zugangsdokument ist, ich meine, bis heute, also ich habe meinen Impfpass eigentlich immer ein bisschen mehr so als merkheft wahrgenommen. Das ist eigentlich mehr so eine, so eine Gedankenstütze für mich, damit ich mich daran erinnere,
wann ich schon mal geimpft wurde, beziehungsweise, dass ich das mit dem Arzt zeigen kann und der mir dann sagt.
OK hier Wasern solltest du nochmal machen und das ist auch schon bisschen alt und das hast du ja noch gar nicht.
Durchimpfen. Aber ich hab's nie so wirklich als Nachweis benutzt mit der Ausnahme einer,
Reise nach Südamerika, wo ich halt Gelbfieberimpfung tatsächlich nachweisen musste. Das war so der einzige Moment. Aber jetzt mit diesem.
Mit dieser Diskussion, ne? Der der Privilegien oder äh Einschränkungsaufhebung et cetera ähm kriegt das natürlich nochmal eine ganz andere Dimension.
Ja das tut es in der Tat.
Denkst du denn, dass es technisch machbar ist?
Was im digitalen.
Na ja, ich meine, wie würdest du dir so einen Nachweis vorstellen? Träume natürlich alle davon, dass wir da wieder was auf dem Smartphone ist.
Und äh QR-Codes und all dieser ganze Kram nur ist schnell kopiert, so.
Oder vielleicht eben auch äh schnell gehackt und nachgemacht, wenn das nicht wirklich abgesichert ist.
Muss ja durch irgendwas.
Sei es vielleicht auch kryptographisch abgesichert werden, da muss eine komplette Sicherheitskette dahinter stehen was es da sozusagen der Erlass, wie kriege ich diesen Code und wer liest den aus und welche Infrastruktur überprüft den,
Also es muss ja alles da sein.
Ja. Also ich denke mal einen äh internationaler Impfausweis ist,
wäre einfach, dass das Ding äh der der Wahl. So, ich meine, die WHO.
Hat halt so das Format, das Ding was du hattest, war das äh irgendwie auch kompatibel damit ähm oder war das, hat braucht das so einen internationalen Impfausweis.
Brauchtest du nicht, du kannst mit deinem Deutschen oder äh.
Gelbe ist der internationale eigentlich. Also da ist dann, wenn da ein WHO-Logo vorne drauf ist, äh dann ist das der international.
Mhm. Und den müsste es dann in Digital geben.
Also,
Ich bin da skeptisch. Äh ich meine, ich habe auch viele Projekte erlebt oder es, also das Problem ja, wäre lösbar, ist teilweise lösbar, aber äh,
Ähnliches Ding mit Studenten ausweisen, ja? Ähm oder ja, also.
Äh ich ich sehe nicht, dass das irgendwie in absehbarer Zeit irgendwas Digitales da an Start kommt. Da glaube ich einfach nicht dran.
Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass man das brauchen wird, weil ich glaube nicht, dass man dann.
Ständig irgendwie so ein Impfpass irgendwo vorzeigen muss, also an so einem Szenario glaube ich jetzt nicht, dass.
Weiß ich nicht, du.
Dich nur mit mit Impfpass bewegen kannst, sind das irgendwie bei der U-Bahn und bei in jedem Geschäft und weiß ich nicht. Also glaube ich nicht. Das ist sowas.
Geben wird.
Ja, das wäre ja so ein bisschen die die Dystopie, ne? Dass man sozusagen nur noch ins Restaurant reinkommt mit so einem.
Ja, also also eher eher noch machen wir bei uns einen richtigen Logdown, bevor das passiert.
Ein richtiger Lokdown. Du gibst die Hoffnung nicht auf.
Also für mich ja alles, was irgendwie kein R unter null sieben oder null sieben oder weniger bringt, ist für mich kein richtiger Lock.
Gut, kommen wir nochmal zu den Impfstoffen und was es da eigentlich so Neues gibt,
Ein bisschen haben wir das ja auch schon angesprochen, vielleicht nochmal ein kurzer Schwenk nach Israel,
blicken wir ja immer so drauf und schauen mal, aha okay, wie viel sind denn jetzt geimpft und was lässt sich denn da rauslesen.
Fünfzig Prozent der Bevölkerung haben jetzt die erste Dosis erhalten,
Also soweit sind wir da jetzt schon, ne? Und fünfunddreißig Prozent haben die zweite Dosis erhalten,
Das ganze Infektionsgeschehen ist aber noch nicht im Griff und die haben jetzt auch in den letzten Tagen wieder leicht steigende Zahlen gehabt. So, also selbst mit fünfzig Prozent Beimpfung geht da noch nichts automatisch weg.
Das kann man glaube ich schon mal festhalten. Jetzt äh gab's ja die Frage.
Inwiefern hilft jetzt äh der Biontech Pfeiser Impfstoff, der da ja zum Einsatz kommt.
Auch gegen Infektion. Ist mir gar nicht so sicher, haben wir das letzte Woche eigentlich schon angesprochen? Glaube schon, ne?
Weise. Kann man ja nochmal wiederholen. Also es gab diesen Bericht, dass ähm.
Eine Studie gezeigt habe, dass äh neunundachtzig Prozent.
Neunundachtzig Prozent der geimpften irgendwie Infektionen verhindert wurden im Vergleich zu einer Vergleichsgruppe.
Da gab's dann so diversen Einspruch dagegen
dass man doch jetzt diese Zahl nicht einfach mal so nehmen konnte, weil natürlich die Testraten andere waren, während also ungeimpfte in Israel sich halt regelmäßig beim Ein- und Ausreise äh testen lassen müssen und generell natürlich auch,
eher dazu tendieren, sich öfter mal zu testen, weil die wollen natürlich wissen, bin ich, habe ich jetzt eine Infektion oder nicht und in dem Moment, wo du geimpft bist, denke ich mal, gehst du dann schon deutlich entspannter durchs Leben.
Und das sind natürlich solche Sachen, die man da einrechnen muss und deswegen gab's da so ein bisschen Vorbehalte, da dachte ich mir so, ja okay, gut, passt schon, irgendwie kann man kann man wahrscheinlich ähm so sehen, warten wir mal ab, was sich dabei so ergibt.
Wenn man natürlich auch sagen muss, dass die Grunderwartung immer noch positiv ist, weil neunundachtzig Prozent schon eine Ansage. Also selbst wenn du da noch ein paar Korrekturen einziehst, dann dann bleibt da eine relativ hohe Zahl bei äh über,
oder zumindest könnte man das erwarten, da macht man so, ne? Kann man das ja jetzt nicht direkt mathematisch irgendwas runterrechnen, sondern man muss mal genau hinschauen. Wie auch immer. Und während die.
Diskussion dadrüber noch läuft oder ich zumindest noch nicht gesehen habe, ob sie schon äh weitere Nahrung durch äh weitere Methodiken oder Zahlen bekommen hat, gibt's dann auch noch eine weitere Studie, diesmal aus Schottland
die im Prinzip genau dasselbe rausgefunden hat, dass also hier
nach einer einzelnen Dosis von dem Pfeiser ähm Wachzin.
Zweiundsiebzig Prozent äh nee warte mal zweiundsiebzig Prozent.
Nach einundzwanzig Tagen.
Einundzwanzig Tagen. Genau und sechsundachtzig Prozent sieben Tage nach der zweiten Dosis, also,
die Infektion ähm zurückgehen, ne? Also diese
Effektivität, die er immer diskutiert wird, da muss man halt immer unterscheiden, welche Effektivität ist gemeint, Effektivität bei der Verhinderung der Krankheit
oder Effektivität bei der Verhinderung von Infektion und während wir halt wissen und das war ja das, womit sich die Phase drei Studien im Wesentlichen beschäftigt haben. Ja, die haben immer geschaut,
Inwiefern verhindert das die Krankheit? Also eine symptomatische Erkrankung und dann natürlich auch die Frage.
Wie schwer sind denn diese Erkrankungen, wo wir ja bei allen Wachstinen bisher extrem gute Zahlen haben, weil im Wesentlichen eigentlich von.
Bei allen Probanden, also es gab keine Todesfälle, ja, also das Fakzin hat immer Todesfall verhindert.
Ähm zeigt sich halt also jetzt auch hier ein zweites Mal, dass äh Infektion und zwar sowohl symptomatische als auch asymptomatische Infektionen hier einfach,
effektiv reduziert werden. Das ist eigentlich die Nachricht, die wir ja hören wollen. Man wird geimpft,
Die Impfung verhindert nicht nur den Tod oder die Erkrankung oder langfristige Probleme, sondern oder auch kurzfristige Probleme, äh sondern es verhindert eben auch die Weitergabe des Virus und das findet halt,
statt, ja? Zumindest mit dem Wildtyp, aber eben auch mit B eins eins sieben und bei dieser Studie zum Beispiel war B eins eins sieben schon das.
Die dominante Variante, die dort herumging, ne? Das heißt, auch diese Variante, die in Deutschland jetzt stark ist.
Auch hier kann man davon ausgehen, dass der Biontech ähm.
Da entsprechend hilft und ähnlich sieht's wohl aus auch bei Astra Seneka, zumindest gibt's eine zweite ähm Geschichte auch aus UK, wo einfach.
War das auch.
Ja Schottland war die Studie, die ich jetzt gerade eben genannt habe, weil das, ja, das andere ist auch schottisch, genau und das ist nochmal eine zweite Feststellung, die sich jetzt einfach auf Hospitalisierung bezogen hat,
Also wie sehr führt es dazu in bestimmten Gruppen
dass eben Krankenhausbullsuche zurückgehen und die meinten halt vier Wochen nach der ersten Dosis mit Pfeiser oder Astra Senika.
Äh gegen die äh Hospitalisierung stark zurück und zwar im Falle von Phaiser bei fünfundachtzig Prozent, im Falle von Astra Sinnika sogar bei vierundneunzig Prozent,
Ganz interessant. Also beide zusammengerechnet irgendwie ähm äh einundachtzig Prozent Wirksamkeit bei der achtzig Plus ähm Gruppe.
Also mein die Studien äh.
So haben auch äh oder zumindest die die letzte, die ich mir äh angeguckt habe äh,
die hatten auch durchaus äh,
ja Anzahl von von Patienten und und Fällen äh dass ja die Zahlen jetzt nicht schlecht
sind oder auch ja selbst für Altersgruppen und nach Wachsinen getrennt man da,
doch auf ziemlich gute Konfidenzintervalle kommt an,
der Stelle, sie sind durchaus schon aussagekräftig, könnten bisschen mehr sein für meinen Geschmack, so irgendwie nochmal Faktor zehn würde das Ganze nochmal ein bisschen genauer äh machen, aber.
Insgesamt werte ich diese Studie doch als ganz, ganz wichtiges,
dafür, dass ähm ja alle Befürchtungen, die sich um äh Astra Sinnica-Wirkung bei älteren äh Ranken
gegenstandslos sind beziehungsweise sogar umgekehrt. So ist das Astra, Sinnika,
gerade wenn's nur um die erste Dosis geht.
'ne schnellere und stärkere Immunität aufbaut als jetzt Bayern Tech.
Extrem wahrscheinlich, ähm dass dem so ist.
Ja ähm und.
Äh insofern hatten wir auch vorhin das Thema, gibt's eigentlich jetzt überhaupt.
Auch ähm gar keinen sachlichen Grund mehr äh jetzt diese Empfehlung aufrechtzuerhalten mit äh Astra Sinneka keine Älteren zu,
impfen. So, das ist aus meiner Sicht jetzt gegenstandslos geworden. Wir werden sehen, wie lange das jetzt noch dauert, bis dann auch ähm
haben die ständige Impfkommission dann zu dieser Einschätzung
gelangt. Keine Ahnung, ich glaube, sie wird irgendwann zu dieser Einschätzung gelangen und dann denke ich, wird,
diese Altersbegrenzung auch in Deutschland endlich wegfallen. Ja.
Weil also speziell, man kann sagen äh.
In England werden mit Astra Sinnika äh habe ich mittlerweile alle Altersgruppen geimpft und äh da ist jetzt nichts Negatives aufgefallen,
was halt auch so ein bisschen die These bestätigt ist, dass
wenn man noch mehr anekdotische Evidenz, das ist jetzt nicht mehr nur noch in gleich eins, sondern äh ich habe jetzt aus verschiedenen Quellen
so die Beobachtung gerade aus aus Kliniken und aus dem persönlichen Umfeld teilweise dass halt,
die Impfreaktionen bei Astra Sinnica bei der Erstimpfung stärker sind,
als bei Bion Tech, aber äh sagen manche Leute halt bei der oder.
Viele Leute bei der zweiten Dosis mit
ähm Bayern Tech halt eine stärkere Reaktion haben als bei der ersten Dosis während es bei Astra Senika tendenziell eher umgekehrt ist
aber ja viele Leute berichten auch entweder von keinen Impfreaktionen, das kommt halt auch auch oft vor, es,
aber ein großer Teil Spürzeug natürlich und
Eigentlich ist das ganz gut, wenn man's spürt, weil das ist ein Zeichen dafür, ähm, dass da auch was passiert beim Immunsystem.
Man sollte auch von mehr von Reaktionswirkung sprechen als von Nebenwirkungen, weil das klingt immer so ein bisschen als ob das nicht dazu gehört, ne?
Nee, ich ich glaube, ich spreche auch grundsätzlich immer von Impfreaktionen und nicht von Nebenwirkungen.
Ja, aber es ist so im allgemeinen Sprech äh hat sich das na.
Genau, äh eigentlich ist es die Hauptwirkung.
Ja, könnte man auch so sagen.
Ja, wo wir gerade bei der Wirkung von Viren sind. Ich habe mir mal ähm ich hatte letzte Woche ja diese Seite empfohlen, How Nine, Weck Seens Work oder so.
Wo quasi für alle derzeit aktiv entweder schon im Einsatz befindlichen Impfstoffe beziehungsweise für die Kandidaten der nächsten Runde mal ähm.
Schön illustriert wurde, einzeln für jeden Wirkstoff, wie genau und wo genau diese.
Äh Impfstoffe denn eigentlich im Körper angreifen und wodurch sie wirken. Das ist einfach eine schöne,
Ressource einfach auch,
schnell mal nachzuschlagen, ohne viel Vergleichen zu müssen, weil er mehr oder weniger von oben bis unten in der Webseite einfach so der komplette Ablauf einmal drin ist und das eben auch grafisch äh herausgearbeitet ist, sodass man irgendwie eine
Vorstellung davon im Kopf bekommen hat. Und dabei ist mir so ein bisschen aufgefallen und habe da mal so eine kleine Tabelle gemacht.
Dass ähm man darüber diese Impfstoffe, die jetzt gerade im Gespräch sind.
Auf so ein paar Sachen ganz interessant reduzieren kann. Also zunächst einmal.
Derzeit sind im Wesentlichen vier Verfahren wie ein Impfstoff funktioniert in der Welt.
Viel haben wir jetzt hier über die Irren A Impfstoffe gesprochen, ja? Klar, Bayerntech, Pfeiser und der moderne Impfstoff, das fällt in diese Kategorie
Dann haben wir diese Vektorimpfstoffe,
also wo ein anderes Virus genommen wird, dem dann quasi eine andere Botschaft eingeimpft wird, dass Virus selber schlägt zwar im Körper auf.
Kann aber mit diesem Körper eigentlich gar nichts anfangen, ne, weil wie zum Beispiel bei Astra Sinica ist ein Virus, der eigentlich für Schimpansen gemacht ist, interessiert interessiert sich nicht für einen Menschen und umgekehrt. Ähm.
Also es sind nicht nicht fortpflanzungsfähige Viren
die zwar Zellen befallen können so und bestimmte eben
Proteinproduktion ankurbeln können, aber nicht äh die Gene enthalten, um selber Kopien von sich herzustellen.
Genau.
Diese beiden äh Typen auf die anderen beiden komme ich gleich noch. Die haben alle dasselbe, also alle haben dasselbe Ziel. So, es geht eigentlich immer dadrum, man will dieses Protein des Bikes.
Das möchte man ganz gerne ähm dem Immunsystem präsentieren, wie das so schön heißt,
auf das diese Immunreaktion losgeht und die sich einfach genau gegen dieses Angriffsbild.
Wappnet. Das ist sozusagen das Ziel. Das heißt, egal was man tut.
Am Ende muss immer dieses Bike-Protein vorhanden sein. Das kann man glaube ich damit kann man sozusagen alle zusammenfassen. So funktionieren eigentlich alle nur der Weg dahin. Der ist unterschiedlich.
Beim A ist es so oder fangen wir mal mit den Viktorimpfoffen an, so. Da ist dann halt DN.
Warst noch nicht du warst noch nicht.
War noch nicht, ich war noch nicht durch, weil komme ich gleich drauf. Ähm in den Vektorimpfstoffen, da ist halt irgendwie DNA drin.
Und diese dadurch, dass sie in diesen anderen Virus eingesetzt sind, gräbt sich sozusagen der Virus erstmal ein und,
diese Vektorimpfstoffe, die nehmen sozusagen den längsten Weg, die kommen in den Körper rein,
Kunden, die sich hier oben, sagen so, hey, was ist denn hier los? Gibt's hier irgendwelche Zellen? Ah, da ist ja eine. Geht in die Zelle rein.
Aber auch dort kann diese DNA noch nicht funktionieren, weil DNA muss erstmal abgelesen werden, damit daraus was entstehen kann. Also der Viktorimpfoff geht halt.
In den Zellkern rein. Das ist sozusagen der tiefste Weg, den ein Impfstoff gehen kann und das haben wir bei diesen Viktorimpfstoffen.
Ne, der Informationsträger ist DNA und erst wenn dann das im Zellkern angekommen ist, dann geht diese Replikationmechanismen los. Das halt aus der DNA eine Kopie gemacht wird,
Herrena erzeugt wird, die geht dann wieder,
in die Zelle, also dieses Cytoplasma, der eigentlichen Zellumhüllung rein und dort geht dann halt die Maschine los und es wird eben aus dieser äh kurz zuvor erzeugten RNA äh.
Protein erzeugt und das geht dann in äh über die Zellwand zum Körper und das Immunsystem schlägt an.
MRNA-Impfstoffe, also Bayerntisch, Pfeiser, moderner, die lassen quasi einen Schritt weg, indem sie einfach direkt eben diese MRNA schon reinbringen. Das heißt, hier muss man nicht in den Zellkern reingehen,
sondern nur in die Zellhülle. Ist schon mal ein,
etwas weniger invasiv als dieser äh Vektor im Stoff.
Aber das Ziel ist ja immer dasselbe, das Ziel ist immer, dass Protein zu erzeugen. Und dann kann man sich natürlich auch fragen, ja, hm, aber.
Warum nimmt man nicht gleich das Protein? Ja, warum noch diesen ganzen anderen äh Schranz drumherum? Und das ist das, was.
Novawax macht, die Firma Novawax hat halt einen Impfstoff jetzt auch äh in Phase drei. Das heißt, es ist davon auszugehen, dass die jetzt demnächst auch noch hier mit dazu kommen.
Und äh das ist dann sozusagen ein Protein im Stoff
Das heißt, hier wird dieses Bike-Protein schon außerhalb erzeugt, also sie haben einen Weg gefunden, äh indem sie das in so andere Viren, in Kulturen und so weiter äh reinpacken
große Mengen von diesen Proteinen einfach zu erzeugen und dann wird der einfach direkt dieses Bike Protein,
ohne Virus dran, natürlich geimpft und das soll dann eben dieselbe Wirkung haben. Also nochmal weniger, weil der geht noch nicht mal mehr in die Zellen rein.
Sondern das schwimmt dann sozusagen einfach nur rum.
Und dann kommen gleich die äh Immunpolizei und sagt, was ist das hier? Spike-Proteinen, wo man hier nicht haben, Alarm und los geht's, ne? Aber wie auch mit dem vom Körper produzierten,
Protein, Spike-Protein, die machen so erstmal selber nichts. So, also dieses Bike-Protein klebt zwar an diesen,
saß Virus dran, aber das ist an sich nicht das, was äh das Ding so gefährlich macht.
Die vierte Kategorie von Impfstoffen, die es noch gibt, sind die sogenannten inaktivierten Viren.
Und da würde man ja irgendwie auch äh erwarten, dass das so ein bisschen so ähnlich ist wie diese Vektorviren, aber ist ja eigentlich nicht so, weil die sind ja inaktiviert, die sind,
Wie man so schön sagt, tot, also die Diskussion, ob ein Virus überhaupt lebt, ist ja sozusagen nochmal so an sich eine ganz äh philosophische Frage,
so eine Medizinphilosophische Frage, da kriegst du bestimmt auch immer drei Antworten, wenn du zwei Leute fragst. Und das ist der Weg, den so Sinofarm, Sinowak, also vor allem die Chinesen und auch die Inder gehen, also Barat, Biotech, ist auch noch so ein,
So und das ist eigentlich so diese klassische Methode, die klassische Impfstoffmethode, wenn man sie früher für andere Sachen auch zum Ansatz gebracht hat. Und hier wird quasi dieses Bike-Protein an diesen Virus rangetackert, also dieser inaktivierte Virus.
Der hat ja, trägt ja sozusagen dieses Protein mit sich.
Und du schmeißt quasi so lebloses Virusmaterial in den Körper, was gar nicht mehr in der Lage ist, ihn die Zelle einzudringen, trotzdem aber selbst,
dieses Bikes halt präsentiert, weil die sind da ja noch dran und dann soll das eben die entsprechende Wirkung haben,
Mit der Effektivität von den chinesischen Impfstoffen habe ich mich nicht so hundertprozentig beschäftigt, aber die sind nicht ganz so da, wo die äh anderen so sind. Also während wir bei MRNA,
ja so fünfundneunzig, vierundneunzig, fünfundneunzig Prozent gewohnt sind, bei Astra Sinnika und Konsorten ist glaube ich noch so ein bisschen offen ist, ne? Man ist so mit siebzig Prozent gestartet und das hat ja auch so bisschen dazu geführt, dass es so einen schlechten Ruf bekommen hat, auch wenn's,
Unsinn ist, weil die schützen zu hundert Prozent vor Tod und äh wie wir jetzt auch hören, auch sehr effizient gegenüber,
Infektion und ich mich würde noch nicht mal wundern, wenn jetzt im Rahmen dieser Nachuntersuchung auch nochmal dieses Bild korrigiert wird, äh der Effektivität
aber bei den ähm Sinofarben und Sinowax, also ist es ähm mit inaktivierten Virus dann gehen die Zahlen halt wirklich runter, neunundsiebzig Prozent, fünfzig Prozent. Ähm bei den Indern ist gibt's glaube ich noch keine richtigen,
Zahlen, aber auch dieser Proteinwirkstoff von Novawax ist sowohl bei neunundachtzig Prozent. Also das scheint irgendwie im Wesentlichen eigentlich alles zu funktionieren.
Aber eben über verschiedene Methoden, die letzten Endes immer wieder dasselbe Ziel haben.
Ja ähm mein,
Gut, es ist immer nicht mit dem Protein alleine ist das noch nicht getan. Also sozusagen die eine Voraussetzung die andere Voraussetzung ist, dass halt
auch das Immunsystem hinreichend gereizt wird, sage ich mal, um äh
auch das Ganze als Bedrohung äh zu erkennen und eben auch ordentlich dann an die Körper äh zu bilden und bei den normalen
Impfstoffen wird es.
Halt ja äh über eben sogenannten Adiwanzien äh entweder Aluminium, Salze äh oder äh bestimmte ja.
Das Fettsäuren glaube ich äh auch, also Squalin und man weiß bis heute noch nicht genau äh wie.
Hundertprozentig funktioniert mit den Atjuvancien außer, dass man weiß, dass hier halt das Immunsystem reizen und das Ergebnis dann so ist, äh wie man das gerne hätte und,
bei ja, MRNA und Vektor, Impfstoffen äh braucht es.
Keine Akjovan ziehen äh sondern da sorgen offensichtlich die molekularen Prozesse, dadurch, dass das dann auch im Innern der Zelle stattfindet
dass äh die Alarmierungsketten äh oder diese Reizung des Immunsystems, was letztlich Alarmierungsketten sind, dass die halt entsprechend auch so aktiviert werden. Was ich eigentlich ganz nett finde, weil die Nummer mit
irgendwie den Aluminiumsalzen oder Squalin oder so. Ja ist jetzt nicht wirklich schlimm
so aber auch nicht so richtig, wenn man's nicht muss. So, dann ja,
muss man halt nicht. Ähm und was ich noch tatsächlich interessante,
dass du meint, dass das eben äh Arbeitsvektorimpfstoffe halt bis in den Zellkern rein müssen. So ähm bei den ja immer die Angst besteht.
So ändern die jetzt mein Erbgut.
So kann durch meine Impfung jetzt mein Interboot verändert werden und sich äh irgendwie der Virus ähm ja,
Virus DNA in,
fest eindringen und äh bei Impfungen ist es eher unwahrscheinlich, aber bei Infektionen kann das halt durchaus passieren und das wissen wir, weil ähm,
nämlich der Teil in der menschlichen DNA äh der aus Viren stammt, wie wir, wie wir wissen äh so. Also es haben deutlich mehr äh Virus-DNA,
in unserem Erbgut als kodierende DNA, die uns zu Menschen macht,
und das fand ich halt dann immer krass, aber bei jedem Stoffen.
Prozente ungefähr. Acht Prozent.
Ja und ich glaube drei Prozent sind's äh die, die irgendwie äh und Menschen kodieren oder so großenordnungsmäßig kann das sein. Ja.
Kurzer Nachtrag, weil du gerade meintest und zurecht meintest, äh allein das Protein einführen hilft nicht. Ähm ja, da muss ja das Immunsystem auch noch drauf reagieren. Im Falle von dem Nova Wachs äh Wachsin ist es wohl so
dass halt diese Nanopartikel, die dann also mit den Spike-Proteinen äh gebildet werden.
Prinzip so mehrere aneinander gesteckte Spike-Proteine sind, das ist ja so ein,
so ein so ein leicht dreieckig äh förmiges Protein, ne, was so außen an diese.
Am Virus dran, äh klebt, die werden dann sozusagen an ihrem Stängel zusammengesteckt, also so wie so kleine Snowflakes sehen die dann aus
und ähm aber dem eigentlichen Impfstoff wird dann noch ein zweites Mittel hinzugesetzt. Das ist aber in dem Fall kein Aluminium oder so
sondern hier kommt ein Extrakt aus dem Seifenrindenbaum.
Satz, das ist äh ein Baum, der so in den anderen in äh in Chile wächst.
Dort auch schon seit Jahrhunderten Teil der medizinischen Kultur zu sein äh scheint und der wohl wenn man eben jetzt diesen Extrak
die ich jetzt nicht genauer benennen kann vom Immunsystem als ausreichend aufregend angesehen wird, um sich dann doch mal diese Brühe genauer anzuschauen
Also das ist sozusagen das, was passiert, ne. Also man wirft da so
so 'ne so 'ne Nebelkerze um erstmal irgendwie Aufmerksamkeit zu so mehr so 'ne Flashgranate, um um Aufmerksamkeit zu erzeugen und dann wird erstmal alles festgenommen, was bei Drani auf den Bäumen ist und dann kommt das Immunsystem und sagt so hier, also hier
komischen Spikes, Noflex, ihr seht aber mal echt echt ein bisschen verdächtig aus. Räuch nehmen wir jetzt hier mal in Haft. Muss man schauen.
Ich rechne in den nächsten Wochen damit mehr Informationen dazu äh kann's gerade nicht genau einschätzen.
Wann das dazu kommt, aber ich glaube, dass das auch erstmal etwas für den amerikanischen Markt und wird jetzt bei uns äh erstmal nicht so eine große Rolle spielen.
Ja, okay, es ist ja, ich sehe gerade, dass das Atiovance, von dem du redest, ist QS einundzwanzig, glaube ich, das genannt. Ja und.
Wie auch immer.
Ja. Also ist ein ziemlich äh etwas größeres Molekül. Hm.
Ja, also sehr viele Wege führen da gerade nach Rom und das finde ich irgendwie auch echt spannend, also diese ganze,
Impfstoffentwicklung ist eine totale Success Story, hier haben sich also verschiedenste Techniken auf einmal beweisen können, von denen man bisher immer nur so gedacht hat, dass sie vielleicht ganz hilfreich sein können und die medizinischen Implikationen daraus, das haben wir ja aber auch schon mal besprochen
sind vielfältig. So, was haben wir denn noch? Wir haben noch äh.
Noch neues aus äh Digitalistan. Die Corona Warnapp, die hat ein paar.
Äh Änderungen erfahren, über die wir hier noch nicht so gesprochen haben.
Und es gab so ein paar Fortschritte, was vielleicht mal ganz interessant, dass man hier kurz äh anzusprechen. Also jetzt so nach Ostern. Langfristig ist ähm auch nochmal eine Überarbeitung.
Geplant, also die App soll.
Eine Clustererkennung bekommen und äh überhaupt neue Algorithmen äh implementieren. Es gibt ja eine,
Date für diese Exposa-Lotification Framework, also das, was Apple und Google in ihre Betriebssysteme eingebaut haben, um diese Corona Warn App und andere Apps überhaupt erst zu ermöglichen. Da gibt's jetzt eine Version zwei null, die ist seit Dezember zwanzig ungefähr verfügb
also mit den entsprechenden Betriebssystem Updates eingebracht worden. Das kann man natürlich nicht sofort
benutzende Cross-Deline, weil muss sich ja auch erstmal ein bisschen durchsetzen, bis dann irgendwie alle Telefone ähm das benutzt haben, benutzt wird sie seit Chrona Warn App eins,
neun, ich glaube wir sind jetzt bei eins zehn oder so und eins elf ist so die nächste
Ähm und damit hat sich äh auch schon mal so diese ganze Risikoermittlung geändert. Ähm.
Und das wird jetzt wohl auch weiterhin angepasst. Also,
demnächst soll es wohl so laufen, dass ähm Kontakte,
schon als riskant eingestuft werden, wenn sie länger als fünf Minuten dauern. Bisher war man da eher so auf zehn Minuten.
Um wohl das auch besser auseinander halten zu können bei den kurzen Zeiten. Gibt's sicherlich Änderungen bei diesem äh Notification Fremdwork äh Exposé Notification Fremdwok
um sozusagen kürzere Zeiten besser auseinanderzuhalten,
und das wird halt alles ein bisschen äh anders zusammengerechnet, will euch da jetzt mit Details ehrlich gesagt nicht äh nerven. Dafür ist es jetzt irgendwie auch schon zu spät. Tatsache ist,
das wird irgendwie alles kommen. Ich habe mal ein paar Links dazu zusammengeführt auf dem Corona Warnap Blog wird das auch alles im Detail diskutiert, wie also diese Risiko
Berechnung da funktioniert und das ist dann halt alles so Dinge die schrittweise in Zusammenarbeit mit dem RKI
umgesetzt werden. Was auch noch kommt, ist so eine Datenspendefunktion, die soll wohl auch in die App mit eingebaut werden und es steht demnächst dann auch mal der Austausch mit noch mehr europäischen Ländern
auf der Liste inklusive der Schweiz,
da gab's ja eine ganze Menge Hickhickhack mit rechtlichen Fragen und so weiter, weil nicht EU und so weiter.
Aber auch andere Länder, Portugal und so weiter in der EU sollen jetzt wohl angeschlossen werden. Und sie meinen, sie hätten jetzt auch schon siebenundneunzig Prozent der Testlabore angeschlossen.
Das nehme ich jetzt erstmal so hin. Problematisch sein wohl nur noch irgendwie so Krankenhäuser, die Tests durchführen und so weiter. Das wäre dann wohl,
nicht ganz so einfach, kann ich nicht beurteilen, ist halt so. Aber na ja,
Ich sage ja immer noch, installiert das mal, schadet nicht, kann aber unter Umständen helfen.
Und das war ja bisher immer so ein bisschen schwierig zu quantifizieren, ne, aus verschiedensten äh Gründen. Man könnte das immer so irgendwie behaupten, aber ein Engeland,
hat sich jetzt tatsächlich eine Gruppe von medizinischen Forschern und zu statistischen Modellierern von der Ochsford Universität und vom Elentouring-Institut zusammengetan
Und die haben tatsächlich jetzt mal intensiv die Nutzung dieser NHS Coved neunzehn Contact-Tracing-App ähm.
Untersucht. Die funktioniert ja mittlerweile auch so, dass sie auf diesem Exposion Notification Framework ähm aufbauen, also Britannien hat's ja sicher am Anfang da etwas schwer getan. Die hatten da auch wieder so diese Eigenentwicklungen und wollten.
Wollten das sozusagen hier äh machen und wurden dann natürlich von Apple und Google entsprechend ausgebremst und haben dann irgendwann die Notbremse gezogen, aber mittlerweile haben sie die App wohl ganz gut äh unters Volk bringen können.
Na ja und jetzt haben sie quasi ähm alles mal ausgewertet, was sich auswerten lässt. Downloadzahlen, Verbreitungen, äh sie haben wohl auch diese,
gemessen, also man kann ja äh bei allem Datenschutz müssen ja die App sich dann trotzdem irgendwann mal beim Server melden,
daraus kann man ja die tatsächliche Nutzung und Verbreitung in verschiedenen Regionen ganz gut auslesen. Das haben sie wohl.
Und haben ausgerechnet wie viel wird denn die App überhaupt benutzt und zwar so aufgeteilt aufgeteilt nach Landkreisen.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt politische Landkreise sind oder ob das sich im Wesentlichen an der äh an äh Aufteilung des Landes äh orientiert, weiß ich nicht. Auf jeden Fall gab's eine geographische Analyse
und dann haben sie halt eben geguckt, okay, wie viel wird denn hier die App überhaupt verwendet und haben das dann wiederum korrigiert mit eben Infektionszahlen in den jeweiligen Bereichen.
Also relativ aufwendige Geschichte, weil sie wollten einfach mal rauskriegen okay,
Hat denn das jetzt was gebracht, dass jetzt hier irgendwie diese Apps äh benutzt werden? Und die haben dann irgendwie so eins Komma fünf Millionen Notifications ausgewertet und äh kommen zu dem Schluss,
dass durch den Einsatz der App irgendwo zwischen zweihunderttausend und neunhunderttausend Infektionen verhindert worden sein.
Klingt jetzt nicht nach einer besonders ähm klarmarkierten Zahl, ne? Da ist natürlich eine riesige Schwankung äh drin,
Ähm,
aber sie halten auf jeden Fall fest, dass es sozusagen eine Wirkung hat. Das meinen sie aus den Zahlen herauslesen zu können. Und sie meinen auch, dass so jedes Prozent zusätzlicher Nutzung,
die Zahl der Fälle um null Komma acht bis zwei Komma drei Prozent sinken könnte. Wie sehr wird die App eigentlich benutzt,
es gab wohl so an die einundzwanzig Millionen Downloads.
Deutschland jetzt.
Nee, ist alles England und Wales tatsächlich. Also das ist äh bezieht sich jetzt ausschließlich auf diese NHAs äh NHS äh App. Ähm woraus man aber.
Im Vergleich, weißt du das? Deutsch.
Das kann ich dir gerade nicht sagen, aber wenn du, also was sie ausgerechnet haben, ist, dass es so dreiunddreißig Komma sieben Millionen potenzielle Nutzer gibt.
Also nach alter und Verfügbarkeit und Telefone und so weiter, keine Ahnung, was sie da alles herangezogen haben, soweit habe ich mir das nicht durchgelesen. Aber das war so quasi ihre ihre Vergleichszahl. Das würde ja so ungefähr so zwei Drittel der potentiellen Nutzer. Das ist natürlich nicht.
Nicht zwei Drittel,
der Bevölkerung, ja, aber sagen wir mal so zwei, zwei Drittel, sechzig Prozent der Leute ungefähr, die das äh theoretisch überhaupt hätten nutzen können, haben's dann halt auch genutzt. Das ist sozusagen so ein bisschen die,
Akzeptanz an der Stelle. Ja ähm dann haben sie noch irgendwie gegengerechnet.
Was denn sozusagen die Auswirkung gewesen wäre, wenn sozusagen die Verteilung einer anderen gewesen wäre, also sie haben dann einfach mal
geschaut, was war denn so die aktivste Region? Also was war sozusagen die höchste Nutzungszahl, da kam sie wohl irgendwie auf fünfunddreißig Prozent der Bevölkerung,
Ja, also fünfunddreißig Prozent der Bevölkerung nutzt quasi in einem in einer bestimmten Region tatsächlich diese App, das ist so das Maximum, was sie erreicht haben.
Und hätten halt alle Gegenden in England und Wales dieselbe Nutzungszahl gehabt, dann werden nochmal so zweihundert bis vierhunderttausend Infektionen vermieden werden können.
Kann ich euch jetzt hier erstmal nur so hin äh werfen. Ich habe die Links auf die äh Studie natürlich in den Shownotes. Da gibt's dann auch viele schöne Grafiken und Sketterplots und was nicht alles, da kann man das dann,
nachlesen und dann kann man das glauben oder nicht glauben, aber ich nehme jetzt mal so mit,
Leute, die sich äh ausführlich mit dem Thema beschäftigt haben, haben sich das mal genauer angeschaut und sie sind der Meinung, das bringt was.
Mehr will nicht dazu halt ich nie sagen.
Ja Deutschland, der aktuelle Stand, also letzte nicht gerade gefunden hat war vom elften zwoten waren fünfundzwanzig Komma sieben Millionen
bei ein bis zweihunderttausend pro Tag die mehr dazu kommen, ist auch interessant, dass ähm,
sagen übern Sommer hin,
der Download relativ stagniert hat und dann im November nochmal die Downloads dann ordentlich gestiegen sind. Also wir haben,
im Sommer sind vielleicht,
Ja, drei oder vier Millionen dazu gekommen und jetzt seit Oktober äh sind ich sage nochmal äh sechs Millionen dazu gekommen. Ja und.
Es gibt ja jetzt auch, habe ich gerade gesehen, die Statistik äh drin, wie viel Warnings verschickt wurden gestern tausenddreihundertdreiundfünfzig.
Sieben Tage Durchschnitt ist eintausendeinhundertvierundsechzig und insgesamt wurden bisher zweihundertsechzigtausendachthundertfünf Warnungen über die App verschickt.
Das ist doch auch mal eine ganz interessante Zahl. Ja.
Ist immer ein bisschen schwierig mit so absoluten Zahlen, aber es will mir lieber, sie würden das mal mehr so in Bevölkerungsrelativität überführen, ne? Ähm aber immerhin, also sie haben einiges von dem nachgerüstet, das hatte ich auch noch gar nicht erwähnt vorhin,
aber ich glaube, das haben wir hier überhaupt noch nicht äh äh erwähnt, weil das war ja lange lange Zeit auch unsere Forderung,
wurde sozusagen stattgegeben. Man sieht halt hier eine Information über diesen Rert, über die Insidenz,
und ja und was sozusagen die Aktivität ist wäre natürlich schöner, wenn man das alles noch ein bisschen,
ja in Kontext gesetzt bekommen würde, aber immerhin. Man hat die Daten, man kann sie sich anschauen, man kann sich verfolgen und das ist eine gute Sache. Auch dieses Kontakttagebuch soll wohl noch weiter ausgebaut werden.
Mit den Warnungen dann verknüpft werden, dass man halt so sieht so, ah okay, hier waren Warnungen und da hat so Kontakt et cetera, also es werden jetzt einfach Dinge getan, die sehr sinnvoll sind, das hat alles ein bisschen gedauert, aber ich glaube, das hat auch viel damit zu tun, dass ich eben.
Man auch erstmal durch die Nutzungsprofile dieser App und im Verlauf des gesamten Geschehens sich erstmal darüber Gedanken machen muss,
Okay, was macht jetzt hier eigentlich wirklich Sinn und ist nicht jetzt nur ein Feature, von dem wir heute denken, es wäre toll und morgen interessiert's wieder keinen Menschen, ne.
Wo wir noch bei Apps sind, es gibt noch eine neue App für den Fall, dass ihr irgendwann mal geimpft werdet
hat nämlich, dass Paul Ehrlich Institut jetzt auch noch eine App, auf den Markt geworfen, das paar Ehrliche Institut ist das Bundesinstitut für Impfstoffe und Biomedizinische Arzneimittel,
Ja, also während sich das RKI halt um das Infektionsgeschehen kümmert, kümmert sich halt das Ehrlich-Institut, um die Impfstoffe als Seuche und sie würde gerne äh Unterstützung bekommen bei der Bewertung äh der äh Impfstoffe,
wenn man sie denn dann erhalten hat, also wenn ihr schon geimpft worden.
Seid oder noch die zweite Impfung bevorsteht, ja oder demnächst mal einen Termin habt, dann könnt ihr diese App theoretisch benutzen, runterladen und benutzen, ähm um dann eben,
entsprechende Begleiterscheinungen zu melden, damit das Pau-Ehrlich-Institut daten hat, damit sie da die Ursachen draus machen können.
Habe ich mir nicht groß angeschaut, weil ich habe so den Setup-Prozess gemacht und danach muss ich halt meinen Impftermin angeben und der ja, der steht dann noch so ein bisschen in der Ferne
Aber immerhin Gips und kann man sich mal äh anschauen und so hier denn äh geimpft werdet, dann könnt ihr da weiter fleißig Daten spenden.
Ja. Pavel. Damit würde ich sagen.
Ja
Kommen wir eigentlich zum Ende der Sendung. Habe jetzt noch so ein paar Kleinigkeiten hier notiert, aber die schaue ich mir lieber nochmal in Ruhe an, die diskutieren wir dann nächste Woche, aber das ist alles wichtiger ist gesagt. Jetzt könnten wir noch ein Fazit.
Oder einen Ausblick wagen.
Ja läuft halt äh wie.
Von uns seit Wochen erwartet und vorhergesagt, dass äh ja.
Die Zahlen jetzt anziehen, dass wir uns jetzt in die dritte Welle begeben haben und wieder.
Ja. Aktiv zur Verbreitung äh von Corona beitragen, wobei das halt hauptsächlich an den Motationen liegt, aber nicht nur.
Wie auch das Beispiel England zeigt, wo trotz hohen Mutationsanteils die Zahlen weiter sinken. Also es ist jetzt nicht,
nicht so, dass das irgendwie schicksalhaft oder unausweichlich wäre, sondern wir haben uns halt einfach entschlossen, jetzt eine dritte Welle zu machen,
so, so muss man das äh halt se.
Mal wieder richtig Welle machen.
Mal wieder richtig Welle machen, genau. Ja.
Und ich erwarte aber, dass die jetzt äh dann zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt schneller hochgehen wird.
Und äh man dann schneller irgendwie wieder Maßnahmen ergreift, also die halt höher.
Aber nicht unbedingt breiter sein wird äh als die letzte Welle.
Ja, ähm, wie gesagt, wir könnten uns entschließen, was dagegen zu tun, aber machen wir halt nicht, äh, so was wir halt tun könnten, wäre durch einen,
Ja, maximal vier Wochen dauernden äh.
Ordentlich funktionierenden Logdown, äh die Institutionen auf einstellig äh runterbringen und dann halt äh.
Mit äh Track and Trace äh die Zahlen niedrig halten. Damit wir das können, müssten wir allerdings die Art und Weise, wie die Gesundheitsämter im Moment arbeiten.
Doch massiv verbessern, weil äh,
Ja, so wie sie im Moment arbeiten, also sprich äh keine Benachrichtigung von sekundär Kontakten und eine eher verharmlosende Klassifizierung von.
Kontakten bei also des Risikos bei Kontakten, die halt
so wie ich das gesehen habe, nicht wirklich auf die neuen äh Viren bisher angepasst äh ist, das heißt, das ist halt alles äh äh komplett
in Adäquat zusammen mit dann so Sachen wie
Pendelquarantäne äh oder so, die Leute dann trotz Quarantäne dann äh U-Bahn fahren und so, das ist alles ja das, das kann halt nicht funktionieren
so ähm und insofern ja wir könnten, wenn wir wollten, aber wir wollen nicht.
Ja. Na ja, aber immerhin äh das Gute ist, ähm es gibt uns die Gelegenheit uns auch weiterhin
wöchentlich zu treffen
und den Rest der Woche darauf zu verbringen die ganze Zeit irgendwelchen Links zu folgen und so äh sich Webseiten durchzulesen und sich zu überlegen so, hm, könnte das was für UKW sein
Es ist irgendwie eine interessante Tagesroutine, aber man wird irgendwie so zu so einem professionellen Internetleser. Habe ich so den bisschen Eindruck, ne? So.
Man schaut immer so leicht skeptisch ins Internet rein,
So, A, was hast du da für mich? Mhm. Ja, nee. Gefällt mir nicht, gib mir was anderes. Ah, das sieht interessant aus. Mal gucken. Also,
auch mal eine ganz neue Form von,
Dauerrecherche in gewisser Hinsicht. Und es auch ein ganz brauchbarer Zeitvertreib. Insofern finde ich das eigentlich auch ganz hilfreich.
Ja, trotzdem äh vielleicht an der Stelle sei auch nochmal gestattet der Hinweis UKW ist ja eine Produktion hier der Meterebene meines kleinen, privaten Podcastimperiums
Mit der Ebene ist immer
kostenlos Werbe und Bullshit frei und damit es auch weiterhin so bleibt bin ich auf die Unterstützung von,
Hörerinnen und Hörern angewiesen, wenn ihr Lust habt und Bereitschaft zeigt die Mittebene zu unterstützen, dann könnt ihr doch vielleicht mal auf meine Spendenseite marschieren und dann nochmal schauen, welche Möglichkeiten sich da,
da bieten ähm regelmäßige Unterstützung, ist das, was das hier alles am Laufen hält und äh ja, deswegen gibt's hier immer schön
Corona Updates und all diese ganzen anderen äh Leckereien demnächst auch noch ein paar andere Produktionen, die wieder beliebt werden hier in der Mieterebene, aber derzeit ist viel äh ja viel UKW und das ist eigentlich auch ganz gut so,
Damit,
beenden wir das Ganze, wir entlassen euch ins Wochenende und die Woche äh bleibt safe irgendwie, verhaltet euch, verhaltet euch richtig, beißt noch ein bisschen die Zähne zusammen. Irgendwie kommen wir da durch,
und ja und ansonsten könnt ihr euch ja auch einen Klappstuhl neben euch auf die Dachterrasse setzen und dem Unfall, den wir so in Zeitlupe hier beobachten weiterhin erstaunt äh beiwohnen.
Das war's. Wir sagen tschüss und bis bald.